Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, episode number 7, Objective-C. Take it away, Jason. Hey, so I'm biking to work now, which is just pretty awesome. I actually, I didn't know if I was going to, you know, like it because, you know, I like the exercise, but then there's this whole, you know, you get to work a little bit later. I mean, it might take you
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 7 期，Objective-C。Jason，开始吧。嘿，我现在骑自行车上班了，这感觉真是太棒了。其实，我之前不知道自己会不会喜欢它，因为，你知道，我喜欢锻炼，但后来发现，这整件事意味着你上班会稍微晚一点。我的意思是，骑行五英里可能需要一个小时左右，对吧？所以你在自行车上花了很多时间，而且之后你还得洗澡之类的。你真是个追求完美的人，我只是说，洗澡是追求完美的人才会做的事，这说明了什么？不，骑自行车，不，这超级有趣，你知道，你会有一种奇怪的感觉，就像几乎是亲自把自己送到工作岗位上，这让人感到振奋。哦，是的，还有那个。不过，加州这边的人对骑自行车的人其实挺友好的。在佛罗里达，我觉得如果我做了我在这里做的一些特技，
like an hour to bike five miles or something, right? So you spend a lot of time on the bike and you kind of have to you know shower afterwards and stuff like that you are such an overachiever i'm just saying it showering is an overachiever what does that say no riding your bike no it's but it's super fun you know you get to feel there's something weird like there's something invigorating about like almost literally just taking yourself to work oh yeah well that too but uh people over here in california are actually pretty uh nice to uh bikers like in florida i feel like if i had pulled some of the stunts i pulled
我肯定早就没命了。真的，如果你在骑车，他们这里有自行车道，这很酷。但如果你在右侧的自行车道上骑行，需要左转，你可以直接切入左侧车道，占据整个汽车车道，你知道，直到转向灯亮起。然后，你知道，完成左转，再切回自行车道。这之所以行得通，是因为每个人都心知肚明。就像汽车知道你要这么做。你知道你要这么做。
here i would definitely have been killed like actually if you're if you're biking and they actually they have a bike lane here which is pretty cool but if you're biking in the bike lane which is on the right side and you need to make a left turn, you can just swing over to the left lane and take up a whole car lane, you know, until the turn signal goes. And then, you know, make the left turn and then swing back out to the bike lane. And this only works because everyone's in on it. Like the cars know you're going to do it. You know you're going to do it.
你伸出手臂。一定要打手势，是的。我上学的时候，去大学的时候，我们必须这样做，这就是当时的情况，你必须骑车，而且这实际上是正确的方法，你必须在转弯车道上骑行并阻挡交通，人们会对我按喇叭并生气，那真的很可怕，但那是规则，就像你必须这样做才能完成转弯。是的，你唯一能做的另一件事，而且我今天在一些必须左转的十字路口还在这样做，因为我还没那么适应，你知道，你可以沿着任何行人通道推着自行车走，对吧，但是
You stick your arm out. Make sure to do your hand signal, yeah. We used to have to do that when i was at school and you know going to university that was how it was you had to ride and it's actually the right way to do you have to ride in the turn lane and block traffic and people would honk at me and get mad and that was really scary but you that's the rule like that's what you have to do to make the turn yeah your only other thing you can do and i've i've done this like i'm still doing this today on a couple of the intersections where i have to make lefts because i'm just not comfortable yet you know you can walk your bike like along any of the pedestrian paths right but
从技术上讲，在人行道或人行横道上骑自行车是违法的，是的，或者即使没有自行车道，我相信规则是，如果没有自行车道，你应该占据正常的交通车道，或者只是靠右行驶，所以请咨询你的律师。是的，没错，但这真的很有趣，而且你可以锻炼身体，这太棒了。我也需要多锻炼，但我很高兴你正在锻炼，希望你也能为我们俩锻炼足够多。好吧，关于这件事有一点，至少你知道，到目前为止，也许我真的会练出肌肉，但只要我看起来还像个骷髅一样，我就会一直感到酸痛，每天都酸痛，因为你知道，你有这种八英里的骑行，所以即使你不锻炼，你也会感到酸痛。
technically it's against the law to you know ride your bike like on a sidewalk or a crosswalk or something yeah yeah right or even where there isn't i believe the rule is if there's no bike lane you're supposed to take up a regular lane of traffic or just kind of get over to the right so consult your lawyer please yeah that's right but uh it's actually it's a lot of fun and uh you get some exercise and that's awesome i could use a lot more exercise too but uh i'm glad you're getting hopefully you'll just get enough for the both of us okay the one thing about it though at least you know up until now maybe I'll actually build muscle but as long as I'm still kind of like indistinguishable from a skeleton I uh I'm I'm like perpetually sore like every day I'm sore because you know you have this like you know eight mile bike ride or whatever so even if you don't work out, you're going to be sore.
我希望你做的是把摄像机安装在自行车前部，骑上自行车，这样你就可以把视频上传给我，然后我骑我的固定自行车。好的。我会坐在沙发上看着你骑车上班。天哪。我绝对会打电话。我们就说我认识的一个人，可能是我家里的人，但我没有兄弟姐妹，会看《Sweating to the Oldies》，就像坐在沙发上吃奇多（Cheetos）。
What I want you to do is mount the camera to the front of your bike, ride the bike, so then you can upload that video to me, and then I'll ride my stationary bike. Okay. I'll sit on my couch and watch you bike to work. Oh, man. I'm totally going to call. Let's just say somebody I know who may or may not be in my family, and I have no brothers and sisters, would watch Sweating to the Oldies and just like sit on the couch eating like Cheetos.
那个人叫理查德·西蒙斯（Richard Simmons），对吧？是的，是的，是的。理查德·西蒙斯就像是，你做得很好，亲爱的。你做得很好。她只是在吃奇多。是的。继续。现在别停。做得好，亲爱的，你做得很好，她只是在吃更多的冰淇淋和奇多，是的，继续，现在别停，是的，没错，他就像是，一二三，伸手去拿，是的，那是当你吃到冰淇淋桶底部或者它掉到地上的时候。天哪。
And the guy was named Richard Simmons, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Richard Simmons is like, you're doing great, honey. You're doing great. She's just like eating Cheetos. Yeah. Keep going. Don't stop now. great honey you're doing great she's just like more ice cream cheetos yeah keep going don't stop now yeah that's right she's like he's like one two three reach for it yeah that's for when you're at the back at the bottom of the ice cream container or when it falls under the ground. Oh, man.
好的。所以我们今天有一个迷你新闻环节，因为我们想谈谈我们是如何开始编程的。是的，多亏了一封观众或听众的电子邮件。是的，一位听众建议我们介绍 Objective-C，我们会做的，如你所知，也建议我们谈谈我们是如何开始编程的。我认为这非常好，两个很棒的建议。总的来说，如果你们有任何想要提供的反馈，涉及未来的剧集，一定要引起我们的注意。
Okay. So we have kind of a mini news segment today because we want to talk about how we got into programming. Yeah, thanks to a viewer or listener email. Yeah, a listener suggested that we cover Objective-C, which we're going to do, as you know, and also suggested we kind of talk about how we got into programming. I think that's really good, two excellent suggestions. And in general, if you guys have any, you know, feedback that you want to give that involves, you know, future episodes, definitely, you know, bring that to our attention.
是的，知道我们确实有人在听这个节目真是太好了。除了我们的妈妈。嗨，妈妈。嘿，妈妈，你好吗？我想如果我们搜索编程，我们在 iTunes 上是第八或第九个播客，这真的很棒。是的，我的意思是，上面的一些播客就像 Stack Overflow，这将是一个挑战，但我认为我们可以打败他们。是的，乔尔·斯波尔斯基（Joel Spolsky）最好小心点。没错。
Yeah, it's nice to know that we actually do have people listening to this. Besides our moms. Hi, Mom. Hey, Mom, how's it going? I think we're the number eighth or ninth podcast on iTunes if you search for programming, which is really awesome. Yeah, I mean, and some of the ones up there are like Stack Overflow, which is going to be, it's going to be a challenge, but I think we can take them down. Yeah, Joel Spolsky better watch out. That's right.
你说我们的下载量突破了 25,000 次，对吧？没错，25,000 次下载。没错。你说我们的下载量突破了 25,000 次。对吧？没错。25,000 次下载。太神奇了。是的，大约有接近 2,000 个独立 IP 地址在获取剧集。有些人下载了不止一次。这很酷。不知道为什么，但这很棒。
And you said we broke 25,000 downloads, is that right? That's right, 25,000 downloads. That's right. And you said we broke 25,000 downloads. Is that right? That's right. 25,000 downloads. That's amazing. Yeah, something like close to 2,000 unique IP addresses grabbing episodes. Some people are downloading it more than once. That's pretty cool. Not sure why, but that's awesome.
是的，是的。有些人，我想很多人，至少那些和我们谈过的人，是在他们的手机上获取它，然后在他们的电脑上又获取了一次，诸如此类，这很棒。好的，很好。好的，所以第一个新闻项目是关于新的，我们谈到了那个，那是上一集或上上集，是的，你知道它会出来吗？果然在 E3 上宣布了，我想那是上周。而且，这其实很有趣。我看到的第一张照片是一个奇怪的平板设备。我不知道，你看到这些照片了吗？这东西看起来很疯狂。是的，看起来很棒。我的意思是，我们在上一集谈过，他们是如何尝试用 GameCube 和一堆 GBA 来实现这种体验的。
Yeah, yeah. Some people, I think a lot of people, at least the ones that have talked to us, are getting it on their mobile and getting it again on their on their computer and things like that which is pretty awesome all right pretty good all right so yeah first item of news we had was uh the new we we talked about that uh it's that last episode of the episode before um yep that you know was it going to come out and sure enough at e3 announced it, I guess that was last week. And they, it's actually kind of interesting. The first pictures I saw was of this weird, like tablet device. I don't know, have you seen these pictures? The thing looks crazy. Yeah, it looks awesome. I mean, we talked about this on the last episode, how they tried to do this kind of experience with the GameCube and a bunch of GBAs.
但这有点强迫你接受这种体验。我觉得那种环境令人难以置信。所以，是的，我有点不相信。然后我看到了照片，我就想，那看起来很蠢。但读到那些真正尝试过的人的评论说，它真的很有趣，真的很神奇。就像你说的，用 Game Boy Advance，你知道，那是他们之前尝试做的事情。
But this sort of forces the experience onto you. And I thought that environment was incredible. So yeah, I kind of didn't believe it. And then I saw the pictures and I was like, that looks stupid. But reading people who actually tried it said it's like, it's really fun and really amazing. And like you said, with the Game Boy Advances, you know, that's what they tried to do before.
但据推测，我想这次他们执行得非常好，人们说你可以基本上让其他人使用普通的 Wii 遥控器，而一个人拥有这个平板屏幕，他们可以成为一个与其他人不同的玩家，拥有更多的信息或不同的世界观，而不是每个人都使用电视屏幕，所以你可以得到这种不同玩家拥有不同角色的动态，甚至在基本层面上也是如此。是的，我的意思是，你知道这种机制一直存在，我的意思是，即使你玩过《龙与地下城》，如果你在初中或高中玩过，或者我知道今天还有人玩它，你就有这种地下城主的概念，他拥有其他人没有的信息，
But supposedly, I guess they executed it this time really well and people said that you know you can basically have the normal wii remotes for everybody else and one person has this tablet screen and they can kind of be like a different player than everybody else with more information or a different world view um than everybody using the tv screen and so you can kind of get this like different players have different roles dynamic at an even fundamental level yeah i mean you know this mechanic has been around forever i mean you had the idea of even dungeons and dragons if you ever played that in like middle school or high school or even i know people who play it today uh you have this idea of the dungeon master who sort of, he has information
而且他有一种控制权，更像是主持人。你知道，随着 Wii 占据了家庭人口，你可以看到和你的孩子一起玩这个，并成为地下城主，帮助引导他们
that no one else has, and he has sort of a certain amount of control, and is sort of more like the moderator. You know, as the Wii has sort of taken over the family demographic, you could see playing this with your kids, and sort of being sort of the dungeon master and help guiding them
比他们自己单独在电脑上玩获得更多的乐趣。是的，或者你知道，在你的足球比赛中使用它，这样就没人能猜出你选择了什么战术，或者是的，这很酷，而且据说是很大的升级，他们说我想比 PS3 快 50% 或更多的硬件或性能。哦，哇，所以，是的，我也说了同样的话，那很好，然后我看到了一些评论，这是一个很好的观点，就是，是的，但 Xbox 360 和 PlayStation 3 现在已经很多年了，它们最好能超越它，而且现在电脑的性能比 PS3 或 Xbox 360 高出一个数量级，所以就原始性能而言，它们实际上落后很多。
to having even more fun than they could have just playing by themselves on the computer. Yeah, or yeah or you know having it for your football game so nobody can figure out what play you're choosing or yep yeah it's kind of cool and it's supposedly going to be a big upgrade they're going to be said i think 50 faster or more hardware or power than the ps3 oh wow so well yeah i said the same thing like well that's pretty good and then i saw some commentary which was a good point which is yeah but the xbox 360 and playstation 3 are many years old now like they better be able to surpass it and um like right now computers are like an order of magnitude more powerful than a ps3 or an xbox 360 so they're actually really far behind as far as you know
是的，我会对此持保留态度，因为这些是专用处理器，他们可以优化它们，因为每个人的硬件完全相同，所以他们知道它会是什么样。是的，完全正确，我的意思是，记住任天堂是 10 兆赫兹左右，但我们无法模拟它，直到你拥有至少 20 倍的性能，所以如果它是专门的，你可以用不多的性能做很多事情。是的，是的，但这仍然是一个有趣的观点，虽然他们会超越其他人，但当下一个 PlayStation 4 和 Xbox 720 出来时，他们可能会被彻底碾压。是的，我的意思是，你知道，我想会发生什么，戴上我的远见眼镜，你知道，下一个 Xbox 和 PS 出来时，可能会支持 3D，如果它们还没有支持的话，我们都会说，哦，为什么 Wii 是唯一没有 3D 的，就像我们现在说为什么 Wii 是唯一没有 1080p 的一样，但我猜他们不是在追求视觉效果，更多的是关于游戏体验和这些控制器，他们确实引领了潮流，我的意思是，现在有了 PlayStation，你有 PlayStation Move，还有 Xbox 360 Kinect，它们各自都取得了成功，但我的意思是，它们都是在 Wii 引入这种运动控制器多年后才出现的。是的，没错。完全正确。酷，伙计。
raw power goes yeah i would take that with a grain of salt though because these are like specialized processors and they can optimize them because everybody has exactly the same hardware so they know what it's going to be yeah exactly i mean remember the nintendo is like what 10 megahertz or something but uh we couldn't emulate it until you had, like, at least 20 times that, so you could do a lot with, you know, not that much power if it's specialized. Yeah, yeah, but it's still an interesting point that, although they're going to leapfrog everybody else, that they'll probably be absolutely crushed when the next, you know, the PlayStation 4 and the Xbox 720 come out. Yep, I mean, you know, I think what'll the xbox 720 come out yep i mean you know i think what
好的，你有什么新闻吗？是的，我要谈谈一些不像 Wii 那样复杂或折衷的东西。我要谈谈《永远的毁灭公爵》（Duke Nukem Forever）。这篇文章的标题是《永远的毁灭公爵：几乎无法游玩，不好笑，极其冒犯》。好的，这听起来像是一个极好的评价。
will happen is putting my visionary glasses on is uh you know the next xbox and ps that come out will um will probably support 3d if they don't already and we'll all be saying oh how come the wii you know is the only one without 3d kind of like we're saying now how come the wii is the only one without 1080p but i guess they're not going after the the visuals it's more about the gameplay experience and these controllers and they really led the way i mean now with playstation you got the playstation move and the xbox 360 connect which have been successful in their own rights but i mean they all came years after the wii introduced this motion controller yeah Yeah, that's right. That's exactly right. Cool, man.
是的，没错，你可以想象这会走向何方。但是，你知道，我看到了，别给我剧透，我不知道是否有，我没玩过这些游戏，但我不知道，我其实也没玩过。我直到今天才知道游戏已经发布了，所以，这证明了它表现得有多糟糕，但是，是的，我的意思是，我想，你知道，我看到了它的预告片。他们真的在针对那些想要在游戏中看到裸露内容的利基市场。就像，甚至，我不知道，你看到这个的预告片了吗？没有。这个游戏？
All right, you have any news? Yeah, so I'm going to talk about something not as sophisticated or eclectic as the Wii. I'm going to talk about Duke Nukem Forever. This article is titled Duke Nukem Forever Barely Playable, Not Funny, Rampantly Offensive. Okay, that sounds like a glowing review
所以，即使是老板基本上也是上半身，这有点像保持我们的清洁评级，是的，是的，所以保持清洁评级，它基本上看起来像是一个裸体女人的上半身，但如果你以某种方式给它贴上纹理，并改变脸部让它看起来像个怪物，就像一个半裸的女性躯干配上一个怪物头。所以，就像，到处都是，甚至预告片里也充斥着裸露。所以，我觉得这正是他们想要的。
yeah that's right you can imagine where this is going but um you know i saw the don't give me spoilers i don't know if there's i've not played these games but uh i don't know i haven't played it either actually i didn't know until today that the game was out so um which is kind of a testament to how bad it's doing but um yeah yeah, I mean, I think that, you know, I saw the preview for it. And they're sort of really going after this niche market of people who, like, want to have sort of, like, nudity in their games. Like, even, I don't know if, have you seen the preview for this? No. For this game?
这篇文章确实指出了这个游戏的巨大弱点。我觉得这是一篇有趣的读物。所以我绝对会看一眼。好的。好吧，我们有两个新闻故事。都是关于游戏的，所以下周我们必须换换口味，提供一些真正与编程相关的内容。是的，肯定的。
So, even the boss is basically the top half it's sort of like this keep our clean rating yeah yeah so so keeping on the clean rating it's it's basically it looks like uh top half of a naked woman but like if you had textured that in such a way and changed the face to make it look like a monster like a a half-naked woman torso with a monster head. So it's like, there's just, and even the preview is just littered with nudity. And so it's sort of, I feel like that's sort of what they're going for.
而且我读到了一些编程新闻文章，所以我们绝对可以做到这一点。我们正在努力变得更令人兴奋。是的，是的。我的意思是，时髦的东西。电子游戏很时髦。我们想和年轻人在一起。我当时在玩，顺便说一句，我在玩《恶魔之魂》（Demon's Souls），
And this article really sort of pokes at the huge weaknesses of this game. And I thought it was a funny read. So I definitely give it a glance. Okay. Well, we had two news stories. Both were gaming-related, so next week we'll have to mix it up and give something actually programming-related. Yeah, for sure.
这是 PlayStation 3 上一款非常硬核的游戏。我不知道我是否能坚持下去。画面很美，体验也很好，我从游戏中获得了很大的乐趣。但基本上，每次你死后，你都必须从头开始，就像那些老任天堂游戏一样，我真的厌倦了反复玩开头，以至于我觉得我无法坚持下去。这听起来很残酷。是的，是的，绝对。好的，好的，所以，继续吧。不，好的。
And there are some programming news articles that I was reading, so we can definitely deliver on that. We're trying to be more exciting. Yeah, yeah. I mean, the hip thing. Video games are hip. We want to be with the young kids. I was playing, just an aside, I was playing Demon's Souls,
好的，所以我们打算谈谈我们开始编程的原因以及我们早期的一些日子，试着回忆一下，清理那些蜘蛛网，试着想想那是什么样的，以及任何建议。所以我想你先开始吧。你是怎么开始编程的？是的，所以我很小就开始编程了，实际上，我来自一个有很多计算机科学专业的家庭，尤其是我的大家庭，所以我的表兄弟们在教我如何编程，他们教我 BASIC，你知道你是怎么做打印你的名字，转到 10，它就会在屏幕上刷屏你的名字，我记得那个。
which is this really hardcore game for the PlayStation 3. And I don't know if I'm going to make it through. The graphics are beautiful and the experiences, it's like I'm getting a lot of enjoyment out of the game. But basically, every time you die, you have to start all over again, and the experiences it's like i'm getting a lot of enjoyment out of the game but basically basically every time you die you have to start all over again kind of like those old nintendo games and i'm just so sick of playing like the beginning over and over again that i just don't think i can tough it out that sounds pretty brutal yeah yeah definitely okay all right so uh go ahead no all
就像，哦，我用我的名字把它弄崩溃了。这太棒了。我知道。就像，所以这就像，什么都没有，然后我创造了我的名字无数次，或者只是一个非常大的次数。所以那种能够从无到有创造东西的想法，到目前为止已经渗透到我所有的编程兴趣中。就像我参与了这个 Underworld Hockey Club，这个我从零开始制作的视频游戏，到目前为止已经渗透到我所有的编程兴趣中。我参与了这个 Underworld Hockey Club，
right so um we were going to talk a little bit about on kind of the reasons we got into programming and some of our early days and try to remember clean out those cobwebs and try to try to think about what it was like and any sort of advice i guess so i guess i guess you go ahead and start it off so how did you get into programming yeah so i started programming really young actually my i come from like a lot of computer science majors in my family my extended family especially and so my cousins were kind of teaching me how to program and they were teaching me basic and you know how you do like print your name go to 10 and it would just spam your name on the screen i remember that one
这个我从零开始制作的视频游戏，我真的很想看到一个带有物理效果的曲棍球游戏，当你身体撞击对方时，会有一些物理引擎在运行。这很有趣，顺便说一句，我前几天在 Target 看电子游戏，NHL 2011 出来了。在包装盒背面，它写着，新的物理模拟。就像，每一次撞击都是独一无二的。我当时就在想，这太搞笑了，因为我在 2008 年就做过那个。
like oh i crashed it with my name. It's awesome. I know. It's like, and so it's sort of like, it's like there was nothing and then I created my name like an infinite number of times or just a really large number of times. And so that idea of being able to create something from nothing has sort of like pervaded all of my interests in programming thus far. Like I've worked on this underworld hockey club, this video game that I made from scratch has sort of pervaded all of my interests in programming thus far. I've worked on this Underworld Hockey Club,
所以那种想法……你应该起诉他们。是的，没错。我也要起诉索尼，因为我现在正在考虑 PlayStation 4。哦，不。你有麻烦了。但是，是的，一个人在地下室就能创造出通常需要一整个团队的人才能完成的东西，或者可以改变整个世界，可以创造一个被成百上千人下载或使用的项目。这是编程所独有的。
this video game that I made from scratch, and I really wanted to see a hockey game with physics, where when you body check the person, there's some physics engine running. And it was kind of funny, and just another aside, I was looking at video games at Target the other day, and NHL 2011 has come out. And on the back of the box, it says, new physics simulation. Like, every hit is unique. And I was just thinking to myself, it's so funny because I did that in, like, 2008.
我的意思是，有很多不同的艺术。有绘画、雕塑、写作。但很少有艺术能让你影响并进入这么多人的家庭、思想和生活，就像计算机编程一样。我的意思是，你可以写一个 iPhone 应用程序，我今天和一个人谈过，他写了一个关于猎鹿的 iPhone 应用程序，它是第二或第三大应用程序，每个猎鹿人都想要需要他的应用程序，甚至那些不喜欢猎鹿的人，出于某种原因，他们也很着迷，就像一个鹿哨之类的。不，它是什么，我猜它记录了
And so that idea where... You should sue them. Yeah, that's right. I'm going to sue Sony, too, because I'm thinking of the PlayStation 4 right now. Oh, no. You're in trouble. But, yeah, the idea that one person just, you know, in their basement can create something that usually takes, you know, a whole team of people or can change the entire world, can create a project that's downloaded or used by hundreds or even thousands of people. That is something that's sort of unique to programming.
像鹿的迁徙之类的，而且它也可以，它有点像用户驱动的内容，你可以指定，如果你知道好的狩猎地点和鹿躲藏的地方等等，但是那种有人在业余时间……在森林里，是的，那基本上就是那样。我在鹿架上签到，有人在业余时间制作了这个应用程序，它完全火了，我认为，你知道，你可以成为一个了不起的画家，但通常你需要不同的赞助商，你去画廊，你需要，你知道，敲开门，而且，你知道，现在有了互联网，当然这一切都在改变，但当我们年轻的时候，那绝对是这种情况，即使在互联网真正接管之前，当我们非常年轻的时候，
I mean, there's many different arts. There's painting, there's sculpture, there's writing. But few of those arts allow you to influence and allow you to get inside the homes and the minds and the lives of so many people as as computer programming i mean you could write an iphone app for i was talking to somebody today who wrote iphone out for deer hunting it's like the number two or number three app like every deer hunter wants needs his app and even people who don't like deer hunting for some reason they're fascinated it's like a deer caller or something no what it is i guess it keeps track
有一种观念，就像一个人，就像你会玩 Atari 的《Pitfall》，它是由这个人制作的，就像那个人创造了整个体验。你会去电影院，会有成百上千人的演员阵容来制作一部电影。所以这种你拥有这种不可思议的力量的想法，就是让我开始编程的原因。而且我认为这种情况即使在今天也会发生。我的意思是，那个故事是什么，我不太熟悉写《Minecraft》的那个人，对吧？他在很长一段时间里基本上都是一个人，直到，我的意思是现在他有一个团队，我想，但他花了很多时间做这件事，但他基本上是自己做的，对吧？是的，我的意思是，他参与了《Wurm Online》，这是一种
of like deer like migration or something and also it you can it's sort of like a user-driven content like you can specify like if you know good places to hunt and places to hide where the deer are and stuff like that um and but the idea that there's someone in the spare time square for the forest yeah that's pretty much that's exactly it i checked in at the deer stand someone in their spare time just made this app and it completely took off and i think that you know you can be like an amazing painter but often you need different sponsors you go to galleries you need to you know get your foot in the door and you know now with the internet of course all of that is changing but definitely when we were young that was the case both computer programming even back then before you know the internet had really taken over and things like that when we were very young
MMO，试图成为《Minecraft》，所以这是一个进化的过程，但仍然，我的意思是，他从零开始自己创造了《Minecraft》，我想他的在线化名是 Notch。好的，我忘了他的真名，但马克是真实的人，就是这样。是的，所以即使在今天，一个人也可以通过编程对世界产生巨大的影响。我的意思是，他通过销售他的游戏测试版赚了数十万美元。是的，我相信他赚了数百万。数百万。好的，我想是的。是的，那么你呢，帕特里克，是什么让你开始编程的？是的，所以我想有点相似，我的家庭，甚至我的直系亲属，我的父亲从事编程，所以这总是存在，人们总是，你知道，问我，我经常分享这个故事，我一会儿会分享，关于
there was this notion that like one guy like like you'd play Pitfall for the Atari and it was like made by this guy, like that guy made that whole experience. And you'd go to the movie theater and there'd be a cast of hundreds of people to create a movie. So this idea that you have just this incredible power is sort of what got me into programming. And I think that happens even to today. I mean, what is the the story i mean i'm not completely familiar with the guy who wrote minecraft right he was pretty much by himself until i mean now he has a team i think but he spent a lot of time doing it but he pretty much did it by himself right yeah i mean he worked on um he worked on worm online which is sort of an
我爸爸是如何编程的，因为很多人认识我爸爸，知道他编程和写代码之类的，所以对那个比较熟悉，所以他们问我从小那样长大是什么感觉。我的意思是，很难说。这就像你不知道以另一种方式长大你会是什么样，或者如果你会变得不同。但是，你知道，我觉得通过他的行为，或者通过我妈妈，或者通过家庭的某种组合，你总是有一种关于解决问题的想法。不仅仅是，你知道，某件事的答案从来不是直接告诉你的，它总是，你知道，以问题的形式被问出来，你必须试着自己弄清楚，所以那种解决谜题的方面总是，你知道，引导我如何把事情
mmo that was kind of trying to be like minecraft so it was an evolutionary process but still i mean he created minecraft himself from scratch i think his his online pseudonym is notch okay i forgot his real name but um mark is real person that's what it is yep but yeah so even today one person can make a gigantic impact on the world with programming i mean he made like hundreds of thousands of dollars selling his beta version of his game yeah he made millions i believe millions okay i think so yeah so what about you patrick what made you get into programming yeah so i guess a little similar um my family even my immediate family my father does programming so that always is kind of there people always you know ask me and I share this story a lot and I'll share it in a minute about
完成，我如何找到答案，而且，你知道，这最终在最初的几次计算机编程尝试中表现得很好。相似，写一些小的 BASIC 东西，只是跟着教程走。哦，看，它打印出了我的名字，或者它在转换温度之类的。看到它解决一个问题，弄清楚如何表达我脑子里的东西让电脑去做，这真的很酷。即使在今天，当我向其他人解释编程时，很多人只是用那种呆滞的眼神看着我。
kind of how my dad was at programming because a lot of people know my dad and know that he programs and writes code and stuff and are kind of familiar with that so they ask me how how that was growing up with that and I mean mean, it's hard to say. It's like one of those things you don't know growing up another way how you would have been or if you would have been different. But, you know, I feel like through his doing or through my mom or through some combination of just family that you always had this thing about solving problems. It wasn't just, you know, the answer to something was never just told to you it was always you know kind of asked as a form of a question you kind of had to try to figure out yourself and um so that kind of solving puzzle aspect always you know led me to how do i get things
就像，我不知道你在说什么，但你知道，这个，如何，你如何告诉电脑做某事，你知道，即使是人类可以非常简单地做到的基本事情，比如，
done how do i find answers and uh you know that eventually played well with the first few forays into computer programming. Similar, writing some little basic thing that just followed the tutorial. Oh, look, it's printing out my name or it's converting a temperature or whatever. And it was just kind of cool to see it solving a problem, to figure out how do I express this thing in my head for the computer to do. And even today when I explain to other people about programming, a lot of people just look at me with the glossy eyed stare.
你知道，你在编程的经典学术中学习的第一件事就是排序。人类有各种各样的方法来排序某样东西，但如果你说，好吧，你如何将其编纂成法典？你如何写下一套规则或步骤，算法，用一个词，你知道，说明你如何对那些扑克牌进行排序，他们必须思考一下，而且，你知道，他们中的很多人，你知道，甚至很难弄清楚这一点。就像，是的，试着整天为各种各样的问题做这件事。
Like, I have no idea what you're talking about, but you know, this, how, how do you tell a computer to do something, you know, even something basic that humans can do really simply like,
你知道，对我来说这很令人兴奋，就像，哦，这很有趣，而且你非常努力地尝试解决一些小的代码片段，然后，你知道，只是获得那种极好的成就感，即使没有其他人欣赏你刚刚做的事情。所以一旦我到了那个地步，我就上瘾了。到达那里是一个有趣的任务。我想这只是受到这样一个事实的影响，即使我的祖父在某个时候也写过代码，并从事了一些软件工作，你知道，很早的时候。所以我猜作为一个相当年轻的人，并且是第三代程序员，这有点独特。我想这是一个很好的故事。没有多少人有编程的祖父。
you know, one of the first things you learn in, you know, classic academia about programming is sorting. And a human has like all these different ways they might sort something but then if you say well how would you codify that how would you write down a set of rules or steps algorithm to use a word you know that says how you do that sorting of you know those those playing cards and they kind of have to think about it and you know a lot of them you know have trouble even figuring that out it's like yeah try doing that for like all sorts of problems all day long
是的，这很讽刺，因为我的祖父也从事过一些最早的计算机工作，比如真空管之类的。哦，真的吗？哦，所以是的。也许这有遗传成分。也许，我不知道。但是，是的，所以没有多少人能这么说。所以这在某种程度上是一种荣誉勋章，我想。你可以总是说书呆子的话，并且知道你家庭聚会中的某个人不会翻白眼，这很酷。
you know and to me that's exciting it's like oh this is fun and uh you work really hard trying to solve some little bit of code and then you know just get that excellent feeling of accomplishment even if nobody else appreciates what you just did um and so once I got to that point, I was hooked. And getting there was an interesting task. And I guess it was just influenced by the fact that even my grandfather did write code at one point and worked on some software stuff that was, you know, pretty early on. And so I guess kind of unique being as fairly young as I am and being a third generation programmer. I guess that's a pretty good story. Not a lot of people have grandfathers who program computers.
是的，我觉得很多人，你知道，解决问题的一大部分是能够，我猜用你的词，将直觉编纂成法典。你知道，我前几天和妻子在玩《雷顿教授》（Professor Layton）。哦，是的。是的，这是其中一个问题，就像，你知道，你哥哥的年龄是你年龄的两倍，你表弟比你大六岁，是你哥哥年龄的一半之类的，你知道，不知何故，那些，你，有一组约束条件，然后就像，你多大？约束条件是这样的，你的年龄必须是一个确切的数字，对吧？所以我坐在这里写
Yeah, it's ironic because my grandfather also worked on some of the first computers like with the vacuum tubes and everything like that. Oh, really? Oh, so yeah. Maybe there's a genetic component to it. Maybe, I don't know. But yeah, so not a lot of people can say that. So that's kind of a kind of badge of honor, I guess, in some ways. It's kind of cool that you can always say nerdy things and know somebody in your family gathering won't roll their eyes.
公式，试图，你知道，弄清楚它，并解一个方程组，而我妻子只是在尝试不同的数字，比如 5。哦，5 并没有真正奏效。如果我有 5，那么我哥哥的年龄是负 3，所以让我们试试 7。当我完成时，她已经解决了它并继续下一个问题了。好吧，那是一个悲伤的故事，杰森。我知道。但当我完成时，我有了解法——我的意思是，我有了解法，但以一种，你知道，就像电脑可以解决的方式。换句话说，我可以写另一个程序。你可以在零边际时间内解决它。是的，完全正确。所以这才是重点。很多人可以解决问题，但
Yeah, I feel like a lot of people, you know, a big part of problem solving is being able to, I guess to use your word, to codify intuition. You know, I was playing Professor Layton with my wife the other day. Oh, yeah. Yeah, and it was one of those problems where it's like, you know, your brother is twice your age and your cousin is six years older than you and half your brother's age or something like that you know and somehow like those you there's like a set of constraints that like and then it's like what's your age and the constraints are such that like your age has to be some exact number right and so i'm sitting here like writing
能够做这种几乎像元任务一样的事情，编写一个程序来解决一整类问题，这真的超级具有挑战性。而且我认为这是成为程序员最有趣的部分之一。是的，这绝对很有趣，而且你知道，就像你说的，创造某种东西的感觉，即使它不是像游戏、艺术或音乐之类的物理东西，但你知道，即使只是创建在电脑上运行的程序，也是一种乐趣和兴奋，构建它们有点像乐高积木，你知道，你有所有这些小块，你把它们构建成更大的结构，有一种外行难以理解的美感，但这有点
formula and trying to you know figure it out and solving a system of equations and my wife is just trying different numbers like five oh five didn't really work out. If I have five, then my brother's age is negative three, so let's try seven. And by the time I was done, she had already solved it and moved on to the next question. Well, that's a sad story, Jason. I know. But when I was done, I had solutions for – I mean, I had the solution, but in a way that, you know, like a computer could have solved. So in other words, I could have written another program. You could have solved it in no marginal time. Yeah, exactly. And so that's really the thing. A lot of people can solve problems, but
酷，如果你知道发生了什么。是的，肯定的，肯定的。然后还有当你看到电影中那些，你，你知道，3D 图形或电子游戏，或者，你知道，巨型屏幕时，能够思考，并且你有点知道制作这些东西需要什么，因为当今社会的很多东西都是文化。我知道你说的，但我们每天互动的很多东西都有电脑在里面，或者有某种代码在运行来帮助生成它、运行它或控制它，所以知道它是如何工作的非常强大。是的，我的意思是，我的观点可能是有偏见的，但我一直认为每个人都应该知道如何编程，即使，我的意思是，不是一种特定的语言，这并不重要，但只是，你知道，一个程序基本上是一组指令，具有某些基本结构，比如控制循环和，你知道，如果决策语句，以及只是，你知道，能够描述你想做什么的想法，无论你是什么，比如清洁工，这并不重要。
being able to do this almost like meta task of writing a program to sort of solve an entire class of problems is really super challenging. And i think that's one of the funnest parts of being a programmer yeah it definitely is fun and you know like you said the sense of creating something even if it's not something physical ish like a game or art or music or whatever but you know even just creating programs that run on the computer is is kind of fun and exciting and building them up it's kind of like legos in a way you know you have all these small pieces and you build them into bigger structures and there's a beauty that's hard for outsiders to understand but it's kind of
但能够以一种程序化的方式描述你所做的事情以及如何做，我认为对任何学科都很重要。是的，是的，所以，让我们谈谈我们第一次，你知道，早期的经历。我们谈了很多关于 BASIC 的内容，但我知道当我第一次开始时，你知道，我做了一些 BASIC 的东西，但我从来没有真正超越，你知道，只是随便玩玩。但后来我拿起了一本关于 C 编程的书，从那里开始，并开始写一些代码，你知道，只是输入那里的例子。我记得我试图通读这本书，而且，你知道，在那一点上，我意识到，这有点回顾。我真正开始理解的第一次是采用这些例子，把它们放进去，但不仅仅是继续前进或只是阅读例子，而是真正输入这些例子，然后，你知道，改变它。所以我，你知道，例如，有一个将摄氏度转换为华氏度的程序。所以我说，
cool uh if you if you know what's going on yeah for sure for sure and then also being able to think when you see stuff in movies that are you you know, 3D graphics or video games or, you know, jumbotrons, and you kind of know what goes into making those work, because so much of today's society is culture. I know you say, but the so much of what we interact with every day has computers in it or has some sort of code running to help either generate it or run it or control it and so kind of knowing how that works is very powerful yeah and i mean my opinion might be biased but i've always been under the presumption that everyone should know how to program like even i mean not a specific language it doesn't really matter but just you know a program is basically a set of instructions with certain basic structures like control loops and, you know, if decision statements and just the idea of, you know, being able to describe what you want to do, regardless of you could be whatever, like a janitor or it doesn't matter.
好吧，让我做一个反向的，你知道，华氏度到摄氏度。因为它应该几乎是一样的，对吧？你知道？所以是的，做这样的小调整，让它成为我自己的东西，这真的导致了理解，所以这实际上就是我之前提到的那个有趣故事的来源。所以我当时正在写，你知道，这个程序来进行温度转换，所以我很兴奋，因为我已经，你知道，修改了这个例子，你知道，它很小，我当时很年轻，所以我，你知道，让我爸爸进来，我说，哦，哦，嘿，看我写了什么。我写了这个东西。它把华氏度转换成摄氏度。所以我认为他当时就像，哦，那很有趣。
But being able to describe what you do and how to do it in a in a way that's programmatic i think is important to any discipline yeah yeah yeah so um let's talk a little bit about our first kind of you know early experience we talked all about basic but i know like when i i first started you know i i did a little bit of basic stuff, but I never really got past, you know, just kind of messing around. But then I picked up a book on C programming and started there and started to write some code, you know, just kind of entering the examples there. And I remember kind of trying to work through the book and, you know, not at that point, I realized that the, it was kind of looking back. The first time I really started to click is taking the examples, putting them in, but then not just moving on or just reading the examples, but actually typing in the examples and then like changing it. So I had, you know, for instance, like a program that converted Celsius to Fahrenheit. So I said,
让我看看。所以他输入了一些温度，它就转换了。他说，哦，好的。然后他做的下一件事就是他输入负 9999999999999。他只是不停地输入 9。然后它崩溃了。他说，哦，哦，你的程序坏了，你需要修复它。哦，那太苛刻了。所以我在编程中学到的另一件事是，而且我认为今天仍然伴随着我，是，你知道，编写某种防错代码，或者至少是抗错代码，或者真正思考你将如何测试这个
okay, well let me make one that goes the other way, you know, Fahrenheit to Celsius. Cause it should be almost the same, right? You know? so yeah so making little tweaks like that and making it my own and that really led to understanding and so that's actually kind of where that funny story i was talking about earlier came from so i was writing you know this program to do temperature conversion so i was pretty excited that i had you know modified this example you know it's pretty dinky i was pretty young so i i you know got my dad to come in and i'm like oh oh, hey, look what I wrote. I wrote this thing. It converts Fahrenheit to Celsius. So I think he was like, oh, that's interesting.
并确保它不会崩溃，以及你将如何让它工作。是的，那很有趣，伙计。这很激烈。所以不用说，今天我非常擅长破坏别人的代码。人们总是把代码带给我说，这准备好了，嘿，你能帮我测试一下吗？
Let me see. And so he types in some temperature and it converts. And he's like, oh, okay. Then the very next thing he does is he goes negative, 9999999999999. He just keeps typing nines for a while. And then it crashed. And he goes, oh, oh your program's broken you need to fix it oh that's so harsh so another thing that i learned quickly with programming was uh and and i think sticks with me today is you know writing kind of error proof code or at least error resistant code or really thinking about how are you going to test this
我说，是的，我很乐意。而且基本上在几分钟或几秒钟内我就让它崩溃了。哦，不错。是的，对我来说，历史上，我实际上是从写作开始的，当我非常年轻的时候，我做了很多写作，比如写书、漫画。是的，我知道，我写了很多像短篇小说之类的东西。好的。而且我读了很多书，我想做一个“选择你自己的冒险”。我实际上在打字机上做了几个“选择你自己的冒险”。那很硬核，伙计。这真的很难，你知道。我的意思是，最糟糕的是打字机，你犯了一个错误。
and make sure it doesn't crash along with how are you going to make it work. Yeah, that's funny, man. That's intense. So needless to say, today I'm really good at breaking other people's code. People always bring code to me and say, this is ready, hey, can you test it out for me?
你必须只是继续下去。我决定，你知道，我想在电脑上做一个“选择你自己的冒险”。所以我开始在这个程序中，是 Print Shop。我不知道你是否用过那个。我的意思是，像阅读卡片之类的。是的。所以我不知何故，哦，我制作了一套，我使用了 Print Shop 并制作了一套贺卡。它就像，转到第 3 页之类的。
And I say, yes, I would love to. And pretty much within a matter of minutes or seconds i have it crashed oh nice yeah for me historically i i started off actually writing i did a lot of writing when i was when i was really young and uh like writing books comics yeah i know i wrote a lot of kind of like short stories. Okay. And I read a lot, and I wanted to make a choose-your-own-adventure. I actually made a few choose-your-own-adventures on a typewriter. That's pretty hardcore, dude. It was really hard, you know. I mean, the worst is the typewriter is you make a mistake.
这非常史诗。我还有它。实际上，我正在整理我的东西，我发现了它。它叫，它叫“永无止境的比赛”，它有八页，我想我以前见过这个。如果你想要那个智力测试，把这张纸翻过来。如果你想看智力测试，把这张纸翻过来。它只是说，好的，抱歉。这太搞笑了，因为它就像，你想向左还是向右走，你知道，它就像，你想沿着土路向左走，还是沿着海洋向右走？如果你向左走，你就死了，但就像，没有上下文，它就像，你刚刚死了，所以你不应该选择土路，笨蛋。所以你得到了
You have to just kind of keep going. And I decided, you know, I want to make a choose-your-own-adventure on the computer. So I started off in this program is the print shop. I don't know if you ever use that. I mean, like reading cards and stuff. Yeah. So I somehow, oh, I made like a set of, I used the print shop and made like a set of greeting cards. And it was like, go to page three or whatever.
你只能硬着头皮继续做下去。我当时决定，你知道，我想在电脑上做一个“选择你自己的冒险”游戏。所以我开始用一个叫Print Shop的程序。不知道你有没有用过。就是那种做贺卡之类的东西。对，所以我不知怎么的，哦，我做了一套，我用了Print Shop做了一套贺卡。内容就像是“请翻到第三页”之类的。
It was pretty epic. I still have it. Actually, I was going through my stuff and I found it. It's called, it was called the race that that never ends and it was like eight pages um i think i've seen this before if you want that if you want the intelligence test turn this paper over if you want to see the intelligence test turn this paper over it just says okay sorry it was so funny because it was like do you want to go left or right you know and it was like do you want to go left down the dirt road or right on the ocean and if you go left you die but like there's no context it's like you just died so you shouldn't have picked the dirt road dummy so did you get
那真是太史诗了。我到现在还留着它。其实我之前整理东西的时候还找到了。它叫“永无止境的比赛”，大概有八页。嗯，我想我以前见过这个。如果你想要智力测试，就把这张纸翻过来；如果你想看智力测试，就把这张纸翻过来。上面就写着“好吧，抱歉”。这太搞笑了，因为它会问“你想向左走还是向右走”，你知道的，比如“你想沿着土路向左走，还是沿着海边向右走？”如果你选向左走，你就死了，但没有任何背景说明，就像是“你死了，所以你不该选那条土路，笨蛋”。所以你有没有得到
inspired to do that from playing like zork or another tech space adventure so kind of a weird story my parents did a lot of like shopping like garage sale flea market that kind of a weird story. My parents did a lot of like shopping and like garage sale, flea market, that kind of thing. Like that was a common like family outing. And this one flea market, this guy had the fighting fantasy. Have you ever heard of these books? No. I heard them from you. Oh, okay.
受到玩《魔域》或其他科技空间冒险游戏的启发，所以这是一个有点奇怪的故事，我父母经常去逛车库甩卖、跳蚤市场之类的。这是一个有点奇怪的故事。我父母经常去逛车库甩卖、跳蚤市场之类的。那就像是一种常见的家庭出游。在其中一个跳蚤市场上，有个人卖《战斗幻想》系列。你听说过这些书吗？没有。我是从你那儿听说的。哦，好吧。
There you go. They're basically, and there's an iPhone app for them, by the way, now. Someone's converted them to like an iPhone app, which is pretty epic. But it's basically like 400 sections and each section can be from a page to you know even a few lines so um a 400 section choose your own adventure book like this massive choose your own adventure book and so that's really what got me started into trying to write my own stories and my own choose your own adventure books after reading tons of those i bought the whole set of like 36 or something books for like ten dollars
就是这样。顺便说一下，它们基本上现在有 iPhone 应用程序了。有人把它们转换成了 iPhone 应用程序，这非常棒。但它基本上就像 400 个章节，每一节可能只有一页，也可能只有几行，所以这是一个 400 节的“选择你自己的冒险”书，就像这本巨大的“选择你自己的冒险”书，这就是我开始尝试编写自己的故事和自己的“选择你自己的冒险”书的真正原因，在读了无数本之后，我花大约十美元买了一整套，大概 36 本左右。
um and so uh that really was started the whole thing and then i moved on to basic um you're writing different stories and that and then uh from there it just kind of went on to writing games and uh from games to programming uh you know websites and then it just kind of one thing led to another yeah i mean i guess that's a point too i did a little bit you know i guess it was around the same time or a little bit after you know when web browsers were first picking up and you know not that they were just being invented but um you know i guess just becoming mainstream as it were but that started doing you know writing html which i guess we should point out it's a little different than
嗯，所以这确实开启了这一切，然后我转向了基础，嗯，你编写不同的故事，然后从那里开始，它就演变成了编写游戏，从游戏到编程，你知道，网站，然后事情就这样一件接一件地发生了。是的，我的意思是，我想这也是一个重点，我做了一点，你知道，我想那大约是在同一时间，或者稍微晚一点，你知道，当网络浏览器刚开始流行的时候，你知道，并不是说它们刚被发明出来，而是，你知道，我想只是变得主流了，但那开始做，你知道，编写 HTML，我想我们应该指出，这和
programming is it's more designing and laying out a page um if you do javascript you get into programming but doing actual html is slightly different yeah i mean i just there's just so many some of my best memories are just geeking out to produce something like really crazy one time i wrote like a little 3d engine in flash just using sprites and then i made this website where when you went to it based on the time of the day it would show you like this scene so it was like this there's like trees and like a lake and some rocks and the sun would kind of go over the scene wow and so if you came in the evening the sun like the wavelength like i just made the wavelength the function of time or whatever on the light that was being emitted
编程有点不同，它更多的是设计和页面布局，嗯，如果你做 JavaScript，你就会进入编程，但做实际的 HTML 略有不同。是的，我的意思是，我只是，有很多，我最美好的回忆就是为了制作一些真正疯狂的东西而极客一把。有一次，我用 Flash 写了一个小型的 3D 引擎，只使用了精灵，然后我制作了这个网站，当你访问它时，根据一天中的时间，它会向你展示这个场景，所以就像这样，有树、湖泊和一些岩石，太阳会绕着场景转。哇，所以如果你在晚上来，太阳就像波长，我只是把波长设为时间的函数，或者其他什么，关于正在发出的光
from the sun so it looked like it was the evening and at night it'd be just pitch black and it's just just some of the times like you create you can create something just like totally crazy and this was like flash was fairly new action script like i think one or two or something like that so it's like that's something that like nobody else had ever seen before you know that's pretty nerdy i'm not gonna lie yeah so a big part of it is just yeah being able to make something completely crazy and the technology is evolving so rapidly that any of you guys out there can be on the cutting edge and could be, you know, maybe as we talk about Objective-C, can be using Objective-C to make something on the iPhone that nobody's ever seen before. So let me ask you a question. Sure. sure uh do you think that it's more important to pick a language that people say are good to know or good foundation languages uh you know like people would say maybe java or c++ or if you have
从太阳发出的光，所以看起来就像是晚上，而在夜里它会变得漆黑一片，这只是有时候，你可以创造出完全疯狂的东西，这就像 Flash 还相当新，ActionScript，我想是一或二之类的，所以这就像是没人见过的那种东西，你知道，这很书呆子气，我不撒谎。是的，所以很大一部分就是，能够做出一些完全疯狂的东西，而且技术发展如此迅速，你们中的任何一个人都可以处于前沿，并且可以，你知道，也许当我们谈论 Objective-C 时，可以使用 Objective-C 在 iPhone 上做出没人见过的新东西。那么让我问你一个问题。当然。当然，嗯，你认为选择人们说值得学习的语言或良好的基础语言更重要，你知道，比如人们可能会说 Java 或 C++，还是如果你有
some task you want to do um learn the language that does that task which one would you recommend for a beginner um i think honestly it depends on what the task is so i mean clearly if the task is an iphone app it's going to be objective c but you know if the task is a website well then maybe you should do that in python or php or if the task is you know a desktop application then maybe you should try doing that in Java. So it really sort of depends on what you want to do. I think that the biggest thing for someone who's just starting out, I would say, is to pick a project. Once you know what you want to do, then you can use these podcasts or you can use any of the resources out on the internet to try and find the language that suits your needs.
一些你想做的任务，嗯，学习能完成该任务的语言，你会向初学者推荐哪一个？嗯，我想老实说，这取决于任务是什么。所以我的意思是，显然如果任务是 iPhone 应用程序，那将是 Objective-C，但你知道，如果任务是网站，那么也许你应该用 Python 或 PHP 来做，或者如果任务是，你知道，桌面应用程序，那么也许你应该尝试用 Java 来做。所以这真的取决于你想做什么。我认为对于刚开始的人来说，最重要的事情是选择一个项目。一旦你知道你想做什么，那么你就可以使用这些播客，或者你可以使用互联网上的任何资源来尝试找到适合你需求的语言。
Because in the end, not to be too blunt, but in the end, your first programs are going to suck. And they're almost certainly going to misuse the language. So you might be writing in Python, but in a way that doesn't accurately reflect the strengths of Python. And this happened to all of us. I wrote this beat-em-up, kind of like this Double Dragon beat-em-up game MMO that you could play in a Java applet. And it was terrible. I used all these different multi-processing libraries that I didn't have to do any of that for and just the whole thing Was it's at the architecture is a nightmare
因为最后，不想说得太直白，但最后，你的第一个程序会很烂。而且它们几乎肯定会误用该语言。所以你可能是在用 Python 编写，但方式并没有准确反映 Python 的优势。这发生在我们所有人身上。我写过这个清版动作游戏，有点像那种《双截龙》清版动作 MMO 游戏，你可以在 Java 小程序中玩。它太糟糕了。我使用了所有这些我根本不需要的多进程库，整个事情，它的架构简直是一场噩梦。
But I learned a lot and I think that those lessons can be gained in really any language So if your project is web-based, you know, if it's a applet use Java or flash You know if it's a website you can use Python or PHP. If it's the iPhone, use Objective C, just pick the language that best reflects what you want to do. Yeah, I'd agree. And, you know, I definitely I think you hit on upon a good point, I wanted to call it specifically there, which is that you'll mess stuff up. And that'll drive you learning new parts of the language. So you'll go through some tutorial, and it'll be really boring. Like boring like i don't you know i just want to get started doing my thing and you'll start doing it and you'll you know for instance you only know how to do while loops and you don't
但我学到了很多，我认为这些经验真的可以在任何语言中获得。所以如果你的项目是基于网络的，你知道，如果是小程序，使用 Java 或 Flash。你知道，如果是网站，你可以使用 Python 或 PHP。如果是 iPhone，使用 Objective-C，只需选择最能反映你想做什么的语言。是的，我同意。而且，你知道，我绝对认为你提到了一个很好的点，我想特别提一下，那就是你会把事情搞砸。这会促使你学习语言的新部分。所以你会经历一些教程，它会非常无聊。就像无聊到，我不知道，我只是想开始做我的事情，然后你就会开始做，你会，你知道，例如你只知道如何做 while 循环，而你还
know how to do four loops yet or something and so you'll it'll be terrible and you'll eventually get frustrated go there's got to be an easier way and you'll go look i'll be like oh that's it i just do that and that'll lead you how to learn you know and that's a valid way to do it is, you know, pick something you're trying to do and then learn kind of ad hoc as you need the skill to do something that you're not able to do with the ones you currently have. Yeah. And definitely, you know, unless, unless you're doing this with, you know, a core group of people and you're looking to make a profit or it's your job or something like that. But if you're doing it as a hobby, definitely reach out to the open source community. Post your project on Google Code or SourceForge.
不知道如何做 for 循环之类的，所以它会很糟糕，你最终会感到沮丧，说一定有更简单的方法，然后你会去查找，会说哦，原来是这样，我只要那样做就行了，这会引导你学习，你知道，这是一种有效的方法，就是，你知道，选择一些你正在尝试做的事情，然后根据需要临时学习技能，去做一些你目前无法用现有技能完成的事情。是的。而且绝对，你知道，除非，除非你和一群核心人员一起做这个，并且你打算盈利，或者这是你的工作之类的。但如果你把它当作爱好，一定要联系开源社区。把你的项目发布到 Google Code 或 SourceForge 上。
Get some people interested, or at least if you don't want to get people interested, make your project public so people who are interested can contribute. And that's one way to learn a tremendous amount my first project actually that went that i that i open sourced was a j iso man this javascript isometric engine and it's completely obsolete now but at the time it was pretty cool because there wasn't any open gl rendering in java or anything like that so um i got a lot of help from different people who really taught me how what I was doing was terrible. And taking their advice made me a much, much better programmer. So definitely reach out to the community. There's tons of people just like you love to program. And, you know, anytime
让一些人感兴趣，或者至少如果你不想让人们感兴趣，让你的项目公开，这样感兴趣的人就可以做出贡献。这是学习大量知识的一种方法。我实际上开源的第一个项目是 J-ISO，伙计，这个 JavaScript 等距引擎，它现在已经完全过时了，但在当时它非常酷，因为 Java 中没有任何 OpenGL 渲染之类的东西，所以嗯，我从不同的人那里得到了很多帮助，他们真的教会了我我所做的事情有多糟糕。采纳他们的建议使我成为了一个好得多的程序员。所以一定要联系社区。有成千上万像你一样热爱编程的人。而且，你知道，任何时候
you make something public, you're almost guaranteed that somebody's going to look at it. And definitely stick with it because it is hard. It's and you know i i've seen so many people on the internet do it and i was here myself but you know they decide i want to make uh i don't know what's the big uh first person shooter now i don't even know call of duty modern warfare some dude you come forever okay so you play that game and you're like oh I want to make that okay well you got to understand you know that takes a team of people in the case of Duke Nukem forever like decades but uh in the case of another video game like years you know and millions of dollars to make that and that's not to say you can't make something fun but it's to say that
你公开一些东西，几乎可以保证有人会看它。一定要坚持下去，因为它很难。而且你知道，我在互联网上看到很多人这样做，我自己也经历过，但你知道，他们决定我想制作，呃，我不知道现在最大的第一人称射击游戏是什么，我甚至不知道，《使命召唤：现代战争》，某个家伙，你永远，好吧，所以你玩那个游戏，你会说，哦，我想制作那个，好吧，你必须明白，你知道，这需要一个团队的人，在《永远的毁灭公爵》的情况下，需要几十年，但呃，在另一个视频游戏的情况下，需要几年，你知道，还有数百万美元来制作它，这并不是说你不能做出有趣的东西，而是说
you got to break that down and start learning what you don't know i mean that's half the battle is you know figuring out what it is that you don't know so that you can go learn it and it people say i want to jump into making you know an iphone game well that's great you know and that's a good inspiration and that'll keep you motivated to learn what you need but you got to start don't think the first thing you're going to make is you know some crazy 3d you know phone game you know first start with make tic-tac-toe and it sounds stupid but figure out how to do it because it'll teach you a lot it'll teach you how to interact with the screen it'll teach you how to detect an end game like the game has ended how to start it over how to have a game loop i mean you'll learn tons of stuff just writing tic-tac-toe say okay i'm done with that all right right hangman right snake the you know little snake that moves around the screen and eats
你必须把它分解，开始学习你不知道的东西，我的意思是，这已经是成功的一半了，你知道，弄清楚你不知道的是什么，这样你就可以去学习它。人们说我想跳进去制作，你知道，一个 iPhone 游戏，好吧，那太棒了，你知道，这是一个很好的灵感，这会让你有动力去学习你需要的东西，但你必须开始，不要认为你制作的第一件事就是，你知道，一些疯狂的 3D，你知道，手机游戏，你知道，首先从制作井字棋开始，这听起来很愚蠢，但弄清楚怎么做，因为它会教你很多，它会教你如何与屏幕交互，它会教你如何检测终局，比如游戏已经结束，如何重新开始，如何拥有游戏循环，我的意思是，你光是写井字棋就能学到很多东西，说好吧，我做完了，好的，好的，刽子手，好的，贪吃蛇，你知道，在屏幕上移动并吃掉
apples or whatever and uh doing that will begin to teach you things and each one being more advanced will will make you learn stuff but kind of go through that because that if you try to skip to the end you're just going to get frustrated and give up. Yeah, that's definitely true. And I think that, you know, if you go for something huge like that and fail, you won't really have anything to show for it. If you want to go for something big, like some big 3D platform or like Duke Nukem Forever on the iPhone, you can break it down into modules and make sure that, this is true whether you're a
苹果之类的，嗯，做这些会开始教你东西，每一个更高级的都会让你学到东西，但要经历那个过程，因为如果你试图跳到最后，你只会感到沮丧并放弃。是的，这绝对是真的。而且我认为，你知道，如果你追求像那样巨大的东西却失败了，你真的不会有什么成果可以展示。如果你想追求宏大的东西，比如某个大型 3D 平台或 iPhone 上的《永远的毁灭公爵》，你可以把它分解成模块，并确保，无论你是
novice or an experienced programmer make sure that each piece is measurable you know like start off with a little ascii art top down thing where you're just running around picking up ammo or something like you're like a little at sign running around some world of periods like click you know collecting equal signs you know like start off there and work your way up to the game and make sure that you're constantly rewarding yourself i feel like the biggest you know the projects that i that i completely failed on were ones where i didn't have these intermediate goals were ones where i had this end picture in mind but i didn't have the steps to get there and i didn't have products to show at each level.
新手还是经验丰富的程序员，确保每一部分都是可衡量的，你知道，比如从一个小型的 ASCII 艺术自上而下的东西开始，你只是在四处奔跑捡弹药之类的，就像你是一个在句号世界里四处奔跑的“@”符号，你知道，收集等号，你知道，从那里开始，一步步走向游戏，并确保你不断地奖励自己。我觉得最大的，你知道，我完全失败的项目是我没有这些中间目标的那些，是我脑子里有这个最终画面，但我没有达到那里的步骤，也没有在每个阶段展示产品。
If you can show the at sign, running around, collecting equals glyphs or whatever, that's something that somebody else on the internet can say, you know, this guy, at least he's doing something and he's on a path forward and I want to join this project. And even just to yourself, you could show your friends and be like,
如果你能展示那个“@”符号，四处奔跑，收集等号字形之类的，那是互联网上的其他人可以说，你知道，这家伙，至少他在做一些事情，他在前进的道路上，我想加入这个项目。甚至只是对自己，你可以展示给你的朋友看，说，
look, I'm going to step towards making something awesome. Yeah, and then they may even say, well, that's kind of silly. This game is boring. Well, what have you made? Yeah, that's right. Or they might give you really important feedback. They might say, oh, these equal signs are too far away. Or they look like the two minus signs on top of each other confuse me with the equal sign.
看，我正在朝着制作一些很棒的东西迈进。是的，然后他们甚至可能会说，嗯，那有点傻。这个游戏很无聊。嗯，你做了什么？是的，没错。或者他们可能会给你非常重要的反馈。他们可能会说，哦，这些等号太远了。或者它们看起来像两个减号叠在一起，让我和等号混淆了。
Yeah, that's right and uh you know you might actually learn some of the gameplay mechanics just from your alaskan art drawing yeah and i think you can get involved in big projects but i i think you got to get in with other people because they'll help teach you motivate you show you what needs to be done um and so i know there are some people who who definitely learn programming by getting involved in open source projects and starting off by, you know, going through and reading the bugs and, you know, trying to fathom how to commit some of the bug fixes or even just writing documentation, which forced them to go read the code and think about things and get involved. And then slowly but surely, they began to understand more and more about
是的，没错，嗯，你知道，你可能真的会从你的 ASCII 艺术画中学习到一些游戏机制。是的，我认为你可以参与大型项目，但我认为你必须和其他人一起，因为他们会帮助教你、激励你、告诉你需要做什么。嗯，所以我知道有些人确实通过参与开源项目来学习编程，并从，你知道，通读错误报告，你知道，试图理解如何提交一些错误修复，甚至只是编写文档开始，这迫使他们去阅读代码并思考事情并参与其中。然后慢慢地，但肯定地，他们开始越来越多地理解
what was going on to the point where they could write their own stuff and that's another way to approach it uh i think that's probably a little more unusual i i know a few people who have done that but i think more typical is people kind of starting with small things and building up yeah because usually you know it has to come from you so So, I mean, if you typically people want to produce something, that's why they get into, you know, programming and open source stuff. It's sort of like what, how can open source make me do something awesome? Like, I don't know how 3D programming works, but here's this open source 3D engine that does a lot of that heavy lifting. But yeah, I mean, I have seen cases where people have started off just you know i want to
发生了什么，直到他们可以编写自己的东西，这是另一种方法。嗯，我认为这可能有点不寻常，我知道有几个人这样做过，但我认为更典型的是人们从小的东西开始，然后逐步建立。是的，因为通常，你知道，它必须来自你自己。所以，我的意思是，如果通常人们想要生产一些东西，这就是他们进入，你知道，编程和开源领域的原因。这就像，开源怎么能让我做出一些很棒的东西？比如，我不知道 3D 编程是如何工作的，但这里有这个开源 3D 引擎，它完成了大部分繁重的工作。但是的，我的意思是，我确实见过人们刚开始只是，你知道，我想
contribute to something and uh start reading documentation getting familiar on how the technology works so yeah there have been both cases and let's not forget another important reason to learn to program is like having the ultimate geek credential yeah that's right few classes of geeks are more geeky than programmers yeah i mean like if you thought band was cool programming is super cool okay so what is your uh what is your tool of the bi-week now that we've got everyone kind of jazzed up about programming and uh things like that yeah um so hopefully we haven't lost some of our more interested viewers or they've skipped ahead to this point.
为某事做出贡献，嗯，开始阅读文档，熟悉技术是如何工作的。所以是的，两种情况都有。而且别忘了学习编程的另一个重要原因，就是拥有终极极客证书。是的，没错，很少有极客比程序员更极客。是的，我的意思是，如果你认为乐队很酷，编程超级酷。好的，那么你现在的双周工具是什么，既然我们已经让每个人都对编程和类似的事情感到兴奋了。是的，嗯，所以希望我们没有失去一些我们更感兴趣的观众，或者他们已经跳过这一部分了。
But that's okay. I think we've got to understand there's people of all levels out there and maybe some people could relate to ours or at least laugh at us at how silly we sound. But my tool of the bye week is something I actually just found called flow diagram or ASCII flow diagram, sorry. And on the tune of making your own um first person overhead shooter or i guess that's third person overhead shooter ascii art game that
但这没关系。我认为我们必须明白，外面有各种水平的人，也许有些人能与我们产生共鸣，或者至少嘲笑我们听起来有多傻。但我的双周工具是我刚刚发现的一个东西，叫做流程图或 ASCII 流程图，抱歉。关于制作你自己的，嗯，第一人称俯视射击游戏，或者我想那是第三人称俯视射击 ASCII 艺术游戏，那个
jason's brainstorming here on the show which i fully expect to see uh by next show because it sounds pretty awesome uh this uh tool is a web tool that allows you to make flow diagrams in ASCII art. So you can kind of draw boxes and arrows and lines and, you know, show the flow of a program or of, I guess, anything that wants to show data flow or any other kind of flow. And then, you know, you can copy. It does it all text-based, ASCII-based, you know, rows and columns. Then you can copy and paste that into pretty much anything at that point into your code into comments, into like a mailing list post or, you know, just
杰森在节目中头脑风暴的，我完全期待在下期节目之前看到它，因为它听起来很棒。这个，嗯，工具是一个网络工具，允许你用 ASCII 艺术制作流程图。所以你可以画方框、箭头和线条，你知道，展示程序的流程，或者，我想，任何想要展示数据流或任何其他类型流程的东西。然后，你知道，你可以复制。它全是基于文本的，基于 ASCII 的，你知道，行和列。然后你可以把它复制并粘贴到几乎任何东西中，粘贴到你的代码中，粘贴到注释中，粘贴到邮件列表帖子中，或者，你知道，只是
anywhere it's as opposed to trying to make a picture and draw something fancy and complicated. And the nice thing about doing ASCII art is it's really easy to edit, right? You just go add a few more dashes or pipes here or there and change it to how you need. So I thought that was pretty cool. There's so many times when the best documentation for something is the source code. And so, you know, let's say you used a bunch of training data and came up with, like, let's say you're making a breathalyzer, right? And you came up with a bunch of training data. You got a bunch of your friends intoxicated and then had them blow. meant people with bad breath so you got people to not brush their teeth oh yeah
任何地方，而不是试图制作一张图片并画一些花哨而复杂的东西。做 ASCII 艺术的好处是它真的很容易编辑，对吧？你只需要在这里或那里多加几条破折号或管道，然后根据需要进行更改。所以我认为这很酷。有很多时候，某件事最好的文档就是源代码。所以，你知道，假设你使用了一堆训练数据，并想出了，比如，假设你正在制作一个酒精测试仪，对吧？你拿出了一堆训练数据。你让一堆朋友喝醉，然后让他们吹气。意思是口臭的人，所以你让人不刷牙，哦，是的
so you get people you get people not brush their teeth and then breathe into this breath sensing device and it spits out a bunch of numbers and you know using the different numbers that spit out in your friends testing uh you know mouths you develop testing data data and come up with some equations. You did all this stuff behind the scenes on your TI calculator or whatever. Then you came up with the answer. It's 42. If you take the output of the breathalyzer
所以你让人，你让人不刷牙，然后对着这个呼吸感应装置呼吸，它吐出一堆数字，你知道，使用在你的朋友测试中吐出的不同数字，你知道，嘴巴，你开发测试数据，数据并想出一些方程。你在你的 TI 计算器或任何东西上在幕后做了所有这些事情。然后你想出了答案。是 42。如果你取酒精测试仪的输出
and you multiply it by 42, you get a 1 or a 0. Yeah, that's right. A stinkiness between 1 and 10. But you did all this work behind the scenes that nobody knows about they just see times 42 and they don't really know what's that code doing there it doesn't make any sense so you would love to sort of give them a graph or draw them a picture or give them a little flow chart of uh you know what you did behind the scenes and just
然后你把它乘以 42，你得到 1 或 0。是的，没错。1 到 10 之间的臭味。但你在幕后做了所有这些工作，没人知道，他们只看到乘以 42，他们真的不知道那段代码在那里做什么，这没有任何意义，所以你很想给他们一张图表，或者给他们画一张图，或者给他们一个小流程图，你知道，你在幕后做了什么，然后只是
embed it into the code and uh this that app lets you do that yeah as i just found it but i think i'll be using that because i've done some stuff like this and i had to do it on my own that was kind of annoying so this person i'm sure was in the same boat and they got tired of doing it so i'm just gonna go make a little web app to do that good for them i'm glad yeah it's awesome so what about you what's your tool of the buy week? My tool of the buy week is actually Javi, which is very similar. Is that French Java? That'd be pretty awesome. Oh,.de, is that German then?
把它嵌入到代码中，嗯，这个应用程序让你这样做。是的，我刚发现它，但我想我会使用它，因为我做过一些这样的事情，我不得不自己做，这有点烦人，所以我相信这个人也处于同样的境地，他们厌倦了这样做，所以我只是要去做一个小网络应用程序来做这件事。为他们高兴，我很高兴。是的，这太棒了。那么你呢，你的双周工具是什么？我的双周工具实际上是 Javi，它非常相似。那是法语 Java 吗？那会很棒。哦，.de，那是德语吗？
Yeah, so this would be German. It's a German website. And Javi stands for Java ASCII Versatile Editor. And as you can see from the website it um it's basically an ms paint but for ascii art so um you can sort of like use your mouse and draw like cool lines and shapes and draw bubbles and it lets you um sort of draw different types of uh uh you know borders and embed your text into those it can also do um image to ascii art so it can you know yeah you can give it like a jpeg or something and it'll turn into ascii art and so this is the same kind of thing where like you can wrap a comment block you can
是的，所以这会是德语。这是一个德国网站。Javi 代表 Java ASCII 多功能编辑器。正如你从网站上看到的，嗯，它基本上是一个 MS Paint，但用于 ASCII 艺术，所以嗯，你可以用鼠标画出很酷的线条和形状，画气泡，它让你，嗯，画出不同类型的，嗯，你知道，边框并将你的文本嵌入其中。它还可以做，嗯，图像转 ASCII 艺术，所以它可以，你知道，是的，你可以给它一个 JPEG 之类的，它会把它变成 ASCII 艺术，所以这和同样的事情一样，就像你可以包装一个注释块，你可以
let's say for example you have a bunch of graphs you can export the graphs to like a png from excel or from open office you can import that png into ascii art using javi and then you can copy paste that ascii art chart into your code i am totally going to do this to all of my programs at work now yeah i'm just going to get like random pictures of like logos and of just graphs of of data and paste them into my code. And people will just be like, this is amazing. I know. I've been getting just kind of beat down on my new job on some peer reviews. Because I don't really have the style completely down.
举个例子，你有一堆图表，你可以从 Excel 或 Open Office 将图表导出为 PNG，你可以使用 Javi 将该 PNG 导入为 ASCII 艺术，然后你可以将该 ASCII 艺术图表复制粘贴到你的代码中。我现在完全要在工作中对我所有的程序这样做。是的，我只是要弄一些随机的图片，比如标志和数据图表，然后把它们粘贴到我的代码中。人们只会说，这太神奇了。我知道。我在新工作中的一些同行评审中一直有点被打压。因为我没有完全掌握风格。
And maybe what I'll do is I'll take some horrible picture off the internet. I'll take **** and render it as ASCII art. And there goes the clean rating. The clean rating just went pew. No, but you can have a lot of fun with this, and you can also be pretty productive with it. It's actually quite useful for capturing that metadata. Both of these tools, I think, are fantastic additions to your programming toolbox and they're themed this week
也许我会做的是，我会从互联网上找一张可怕的图片。我会拿 **** 并将其渲染为 ASCII 艺术。然后整洁度评分就没了。整洁度评分刚刚嗖的一声没了。不，但你可以从中获得很多乐趣，你也可以用它来提高效率。它对于捕获元数据确实非常有用。我认为这两个工具都是你编程工具箱的绝佳补充，而且它们本周的主题是
that's right the past couple of weeks we've had we've had a theme i believe good yeah yeah that one time i still have to buy that thing-o-matic i think that's what it was oh i'm trying to save up enough paychecks there's a lot of paychecks to save up it's like a grand right oh no is it i thought it was like 300 or something uh i don't think so yeah i um i have direct deposit and direct withdrawal so it's like just like all that's left are these tiny increments oh man the thingamatic is expensive. So we studied this in school. Money in, less money out means more in your bank account. Well, that kind of rhymed.
没错，过去几周我们有一个主题，我相信。好的，是的，是的，那一次，我仍然必须买那个 Thing-O-Matic，我想那是它。哦，我正试图存足够的工资支票，有很多工资支票要存。那大概是一千块，对吧？哦，不，是吗？我以为是 300 左右。嗯，我不这么认为。是的，我，嗯，我有直接存款和直接取款，所以就像剩下的只有这些微小的增量。哦，天哪，Thing-O-Matic 很贵。所以我们在学校学过这个。钱进来，钱出去得少意味着你的银行账户里有更多。嗯，那有点押韵。
That was awesome. You got to reduce your expenses and then you can – okay, sorry. Yeah, it's true. I need to stop buying bikes. Okay. So objective C. That's right objective c now let's just go ahead and address the 3 000 pound elephant gorilla hybrid in the room okay which is the fact that uh objective c is is all the new rage uh because of basically one slash two devices which are the iphone and now
那太棒了。你必须减少开支，然后你就可以——好吧，抱歉。是的，这是真的。我需要停止买自行车。好的。所以 Objective-C。没错，Objective-C，现在让我们继续解决房间里那个 3000 磅重的大猩猩混合体，好吧，那就是事实，嗯，Objective-C 是所有新的狂热，因为基本上一个斜杠两个设备，也就是 iPhone 和现在的
the ipad so apple apple has kind of a history which i guess we'll talk about in a few minutes about uh of using objective c and because of the the increasing popularity of ios devices i guess as they're known and objective c being pretty much the de facto standard of what you have to program in. And because of that, they've had this kind of resurgence of popularity that they probably didn't even ever have before. And so everybody's wanting to learn Objective-C because it is the enabling technology to be able to use to write the next great Angry Birds. That's right.
iPad，所以苹果，苹果有一种历史，我想我们几分钟后会谈到，关于，嗯，使用 Objective-C，而且因为 iOS 设备日益普及，我想正如它们所知，Objective-C 几乎是必须编程的事实标准。正因为如此，它们经历了这种以前可能从未有过的流行复苏。所以每个人都想学习 Objective-C，因为它是能够编写下一个伟大的《愤怒的小鸟》的赋能技术。没错。
Yeah, so do you know anything about the history of Objective-C? So the way I understand it is that I guess it was originally written as a pre-processor for C, similar to which we haven't talked yet about C++. But C++ has a similar background where originally people were using C and some other languages like Smalltalk started to come out and introduce these object oriented concepts. And Objective-C was one effort to try to give C object oriented support. instead of writing a whole new language compiler, as it were, they wrote kind of an extension of the language, which did become a whole new language, that compiled not to machine code or assembly like we talked about last time, but C code.
是的，那么你知道关于 Objective-C 的历史吗？据我了解，我想它最初是作为 C 的预处理器编写的，类似于我们还没有谈到的 C++。但 C++ 有类似的背景，最初人们使用 C，而其他一些语言如 Smalltalk 开始出现并引入这些面向对象的概念。Objective-C 是一种尝试为 C 提供面向对象支持的努力。而不是编写一个全新的语言编译器，正如它所说，他们编写了一种语言的扩展，它确实变成了一种全新的语言，它编译的不是我们上次谈到的机器码或汇编，而是 C 代码。
And then you could use your normal existing, in theory, really good C compilers to generate machine code. And that was adopted by Steveve jobs small company that he founded uh when he first left apple which was uh next right yeah and uh so there's a lot of stuff you'll see um in even the notation for objective c which is like NSObject, NSString, which is for Next Step String, Next Step Object, I believe. Oh, I didn't know that. I always wondered why there was all that NS. I think that's, I'm pretty sure that's what it is.
然后你可以使用你正常的现有的，理论上，非常好的 C 编译器来生成机器码。这被史蒂夫·乔布斯在他离开苹果后创立的小公司所采用，那就是 NeXT，对吧？是的，所以你会看到很多东西，嗯，甚至在 Objective-C 的符号中，比如 NSObject，NSString，也就是 Next Step String，Next Step Object，我相信。哦，我不知道。我一直想知道为什么会有那么多 NS。我想那是，我很确定这就是它。
I just made that up and it sounds really convincing. So I'll just fact check that. No, I think it's true. It makes total sense. So that's kind of the history. So what is it kind of, we talked about what it's, you know, popularity today is for, but what was it good for? What is what is the reason it exists? Yeah.
我只是编造了它，它听起来很有说服力。所以我只是核实一下。不，我认为这是真的。这完全说得通。所以这就是历史。那么它是什么，我们谈到了它，你知道，今天的流行是为了什么，但它有什么好处？它存在的原因是什么？是的。
So this is sort of a point of contention, right? Because a lot of people would say the reason why it exists is because it's what you have to write in to program for the iPhone. But it does have some some some strengths that, some strengths that sort of separate Objective-C from a lot of other languages. Many of them are sort of more geared on sort of enterprise, writing safer code, and increasing productivity. So one is that Objective-C is both dynamically and statically typed. So basically, you know, just to cover that again, if you do in C, if you do int i equals 3, you can't just say j equals 4, you have to say int j. That means it's statically typed. So at compile time, you're going in and typing in what the type
所以这是一种争论点，对吧？因为很多人会说它存在的原因是因为它是你必须编写才能为 iPhone 编程的语言。但它确实有一些优势，一些优势将 Objective-C 与许多其他语言区分开来。其中许多更倾向于企业，编写更安全的代码，并提高生产力。所以一个是 Objective-C 既是动态类型的也是静态类型的。所以基本上，你知道，只是为了再次涵盖这一点，如果你在 C 中做 int i 等于 3，你不能只说 j 等于 4，你必须说 int j。这意味着它是静态类型的。所以在编译时，你正在进入并输入类型
is of every variable in the system. This is slow, but it prevents you from having these unforeseen side effects. I mean, imagine if you had a round function that rounded a number and someone passed in the word tree. Your round function, it either has to be smart enough to handle what, you know, to do something when you give it tree, or it's just your whole program is going to crash. So statically typed language like C is safer in the sense that you know what's coming in and going out of all of your functions, and so you don't have to handle all these weird corner cases, and that prevents errors at runtime. On the contrast, dynamically typed languages like Python, they don't have a type. So
系统中的每个变量。这很慢，但它防止了你出现这些不可预见的副作用。我的意思是，想象一下如果你有一个舍入函数，它舍入一个数字，而有人传入了单词“树”。你的舍入函数，它要么必须足够聪明来处理，你知道，当你给它“树”时做点什么，要么你的整个程序就会崩溃。所以像 C 这样的静态类型语言在某种意义上更安全，因为你知道所有函数进出的内容，所以你不必处理所有这些奇怪的边缘情况，这防止了运行时的错误。相比之下，像 Python 这样的动态类型语言，它们没有类型。所以
you just say j equals 4, and then your very next line could be j equals apple, and it handles it just fine. Just behind the scenes, it's going and figuring out what j is at runtime and changing that. So Objective-C kind of has the best of both worlds because you can do int i equals 3, and the compiler will know that that's an integer and it should stay an integer. But you can also use this special term id. So you could say id i equals 3. And what that tells the compiler is i can be anything. Like right now it's 3, but later on it could be Apple. It could be a database, a pointer to a database.
你只是说 j 等于 4，然后你的下一行可能是 j 等于“苹果”，它处理得很好。只是在幕后，它在运行时去弄清楚 j 是什么并改变它。所以 Objective-C 有点两全其美，因为你可以做 int i 等于 3，编译器会知道那是一个整数，它应该保持为一个整数。但你也可以使用这个特殊术语 id。所以你可以说 id i 等于 3。这告诉编译器的是 i 可以是任何东西。就像现在它是 3，但稍后它可能是“苹果”。它可能是一个数据库，一个指向数据库的指针。
It could be anything. And so it gives you the strength. When you need to be flexible, like you're writing a user interface and someone might be typing in strings or numbers or whatever, you could be flexible. And when you are doing some kind of numerical simulation where everything has to be afloat and you know you have certain expectations or you're doing something that's mission critical you know you can you can have that have that
它可以是任何东西。所以它给了你力量。当你需要灵活时，比如你正在编写用户界面，而有人可能正在输入字符串或数字之类的，你可以很灵活。当你正在做某种数值模拟，一切都必须是浮点数，并且你知道你有某些期望，或者你正在做一些任务关键的事情，你知道，你可以，你可以拥有那种
security as well that seems kind of powerful and I think that is something that is kind of appealing it's kind of a nice feature although it seems like it might be confusing and indeed I've had experience where that can get kind of confusing to have both dynamic and static typing something else that I found interesting is it so it supports object oriented and it kind of does it in a way that's different than C++ which is why you know both C++ and Objective-C kind of existed and coexist, is the fact that it has a different model for doing, like, the calling of functions with classes and stuff. And maybe you can explain this a little bit better, but I guess it's based on messaging as opposed to function calling. So if you have a class in C++ and you want to say you know this class dot you know foo and pass it
安全性也是如此，这看起来很强大，我认为这是某种吸引人的东西，这是一种不错的功能，尽管看起来它可能会令人困惑，而且我确实有经验，同时拥有动态和静态类型可能会变得有点令人困惑。我发现有趣的另一件事是，它支持面向对象，而且它以一种与 C++ 不同的方式做到这一点，这就是为什么，你知道，C++ 和 Objective-C 某种程度上存在并共存，是因为它有不同的模型来做，比如，调用带有类等的函数。也许你可以更好地解释这一点，但我猜它是基于消息传递而不是函数调用。所以如果你在 C++ 中有一个类，你想说你知道这个类点，你知道 foo 并传递
in the number three then you're calling a function of that class you're actually going and invoking some code that's you know done by a function pointer what it boils down to versus objective C it's a message passing thing so if you did what's the equivalent syntax and objective c for that you're not calling a function you're sending a message to that instance of the object that has hey i want to have a message of kind of type foo with the contents of three and it's up to that class to figure out how to handle that message right so you know that all happens sort of under the scenes. On the surface level it is very similar to C++ where you're calling functions, but yeah under the scenes there is a message passing
进去数字 3，那么你正在调用该类的一个函数，你实际上是在调用一些由函数指针完成的代码，归根结底，与 Objective-C 相比，它是一个消息传递的东西，所以如果你做了 Objective-C 中等效的语法，你不是在调用一个函数，你是在向该对象的实例发送一个消息，嘿，我想有一个 foo 类型的消息，内容是 3，由该类来决定如何处理该消息，对吧？所以你知道，这一切都发生在幕后。在表面层面上，它与 C++ 非常相似，你正在调用函数，但是的，在幕后有一个消息传递
interface and so basically what that means is the parameters and actually the function itself that you want to call get packaged up into this blob and then sent over to that class. And so under the hood, what that means is it's sort of what enables the dynamic typing, is this idea of being able to do message passing. But anything that we've talked about with respect to object-oriented in the past still holds here. So, for example you can have inheritance, you can have polymorphism, you know you could have
接口，所以基本上这意味着参数，实际上是你想要调用的函数本身，被打包成这个块，然后发送到那个类。所以归根结底，这意味着它是某种使动态类型成为可能的东西，就是这种能够进行消息传递的想法。但我们过去谈论的关于面向对象的任何东西在这里仍然适用。所以，例如，你可以有继承，你可以有多态，你知道，你可以有
going back to my canonical example you know your area interface or I guess a shape interface with a get area function that's virtual or returns nothing and then as you implement that shape you can have a square where the area function returns side times shape, you can have a square where the area function returns side times side, and you can have a triangle where the area function returns, you know, one half base times height. And at runtime, when you call get area, you might not even know if it's a triangle or a square because it was created minutes ago, and it's been typecasted down to a shape. You might have no idea as the programmer What that is but the compiler and the virtual machine know that it's a that that's a square
回到我的规范示例，你知道你的区域接口，或者我猜是一个带有 getArea 函数的形状接口，它是虚拟的或不返回任何内容，然后当你实现该形状时，你可以有一个正方形，其中 area 函数返回边乘以形状，你可以有一个正方形，其中 area 函数返回边乘以边，你可以有一个三角形，其中 area 函数返回，你知道，二分之一底乘以高。在运行时，当你调用 getArea 时，你甚至可能不知道它是三角形还是正方形，因为它是在几分钟前创建的，并且已经被类型转换为形状。作为程序员，你可能根本不知道那是什么，但编译器和虚拟机知道它是一个正方形
Triangle and it does the appropriate thing Yeah, so but I guess like you pointed out I mean that's not tip that's not really all that applicable to you know Somebody who's trying to just write in the code. It's kind of handled under the hood, but it does serve to kind of explain to some of the more advanced listeners, what is the difference? Why is Objective-C still around? And it isn't just used for iOS. I mean, it's also used on OSX in the Cocoa framework.
三角形，它会做适当的事情。是的，但我想就像你指出的那样，我的意思是，这对于，你知道，试图只编写代码的人来说并不是那么适用。它是在幕后处理的，但它确实有助于向一些更高级的听众解释，区别是什么？为什么 Objective-C 仍然存在？而且它不仅仅用于 iOS。我的意思是，它也用于 OSX 的 Cocoa 框架中。
Am I saying that right? Yep, that's right. on OSX and the Coco framework. Am I saying that right? And so they use it there for doing a lot of the programming of apps on OSX. So I guess applications are just programs as opposed to apps. I think it's still apps. Oh, I think, I think on my Mac it says the Mac app store, I think.
我说的对吗？是的，没错。在 OSX 和 Cocoa 框架上。我说的对吗？所以他们在那里使用它来做 OSX 上应用程序的很多编程。所以我猜应用程序只是程序，而不是 App。我想它仍然是 App。哦，我想，我想在我的 Mac 上它写着 Mac App Store，我想。
Oh, but anyway, okay. Yeah. I used to always call them apps. Now apps kind of mean something more specific yeah I used to always call them apps now apps kind of mean something more specific than I used it for yeah now it seems to be specific to mobile mobile apps yeah and you know another benefit of Objective-C is it has a really smooth interface so basically
哦，但无论如何，好的。是的。我过去总是称它们为 App。现在 App 某种程度上意味着更具体的东西，是的，我过去总是称它们为 App，现在 App 某种程度上意味着更具体的东西，比我过去使用它的方式，是的，现在它似乎是移动移动 App 的专有词。是的，而且你知道，Objective-C 的另一个好处是它有一个非常流畅的接口，所以基本上
let's say you want to use some C++ like the bullet physics engine in some Objective-C app you're writing. Now this for one thing I should preface this by saying that this applies loosely in the iPhone and iOS world but this is mainly for people coding on Mac OS X. You can still do some of this on the iPhone but some of it is very limited. And that's mainly an artifact of just the iPhone trying to restrict you from coming up with exploits and things like that. It's nothing inherent to the design or something. It's a political decision. But with that said, you can integrate Objective-C and C or C++ very easily. Now, basically, you create a C or C++ interface in your Objective-C and C or C++ very easily. Now, basically, you create a C or C++ interface in your Objective-C code,
假设你想在编写的某个 Objective-C 应用程序中使用一些 C++，比如 Bullet 物理引擎。现在，对于一件事，我应该先说明这一点，这在 iPhone 和 iOS 世界中松散地适用，但这主要是针对在 Mac OS X 上编码的人。你仍然可以在 iPhone 上做一些这样的事情，但其中一些非常有限。这主要是 iPhone 试图限制你提出漏洞利用之类的东西的产物。这与设计本身无关，或者其他什么。这是一个政治决定。但话虽如此，你可以非常容易地集成 Objective-C 和 C 或 C++。现在，基本上，你在 Objective-C 中创建一个 C 或 C++ 接口，
and it just sort of mentions what classes there are, what functions there are that you can call, and things like that. And the API is really straightforward. So if you have, let's say you have this monolithic C or C++ application, and you want to write an OS X you know GUI for it that would be very easy in Objective-C because it ties in so well to both of those languages yeah I did some stuff where I wrote some iPhone apps and it's you know it's kind of hard because like we were talking about before sometimes the best way to learn programming is with really simple things.
它只是提到了有什么类，有什么函数可以调用，诸如此类。而且 API 非常直观。所以如果你有，假设你有一个单体 C 或 C++ 应用程序，并且你想为它编写一个 OSX，你知道，GUI，那在 Objective-C 中会非常容易，因为它与这两种语言结合得非常好。是的，我做了一些事情，我编写了一些 iPhone 应用程序，而且，你知道，这有点难，因为就像我们之前谈到的，有时学习编程的最好方法是使用非常简单的东西。
And you kind of have to do a lot before you even get the first program up and running on an iPhone. I'm sure it's pretty similar on OSX. Or even just the most basic C program is still probably like 10 or 11 lines of stuff you have to type versus just a simple one line you know print in python um yeah so that's kind of a a little bit of a oh man this is scary and you have to write a bunch of lines you kind of don't even know what they mean initially and the same thing is true in the iphone that there's kind of stuff you have to do and set up and work with to even you know get something that you can just draw to or write text to on the iphone um but i kind of having roots in c and you know you know i
在iPhone上运行第一个程序之前，你确实需要做很多准备工作。我相信在OSX上也是如此。即使是最基础的C语言程序，可能也需要写上10到11行代码，而Python只需要简单的一行打印语句。所以，这确实会让人觉得“天哪，这太可怕了”，你必须写一堆一开始甚至不知道是什么意思的代码。在iPhone上也是一样，你必须做很多设置和配置，才能实现简单的绘图或显示文本。不过，因为我有C语言的基础，而且你知道……
maybe i think this would be my advice to people trying to learn objective c programming to do stuff on on the iphone would be kind of learn c first because it's simpler in a way. I mean, there's advanced parts to it that are really complicated, but you don't have to worry about the iPhone specific parts. Not only will you be have a lot more resources to draw on as far as learning C, you'll have something that's very applicable
也许这就是我对那些想学习Objective-C以便在iPhone上开发的人的建议：先学C语言，因为它在某种程度上更简单。我是说，C语言中确实有非常复杂的高级部分，但你不需要去操心那些iPhone特有的东西。不仅如此，学习C语言时你可以参考的资源会多得多，而且你学到的东西适用范围也远不止iPhone。
to a lot more than just the iPhone. And then my experience of programming iPhone was that I was in there, I would do these kind of things I had to do, this little song and dance to get everything set up the way it needed to be to get the iPhone happy. And then I would pretty much just write C code. So, you know, they have all these NS objects you pass around. And I would just figure out how do I get a pointer to the data, the array. And then I would just, you know, do regular pointer stuff and C.
它适用于很多领域，而不仅仅是iPhone。我开发iPhone程序的经验是，我进去之后，必须做那些必须做的事情，也就是为了让iPhone正常运行而进行的一套“例行公事”。之后，我基本上就只是在写C代码。你知道，他们有很多NS对象需要传递，我只需要弄清楚如何获取指向数据或数组的指针，然后就可以像往常一样使用C语言的指针操作了。
And, you know, just do all stuff and see, and, you know, just do all my old stuff that I knew, have done for years, and I'm very comfortable with. And I had no problem doing that. And a lot of ways, that could actually ended up being a little bit faster than doing it the way that kind of they recommend to do it, because it involved less overhead. And so it worked out well for my application, at least. Now, I can't say that, you know, universally that'll be the case, but I definitely didn't feel hampered only having a strong C background and not really knowing what I was doing in Objective-C. I was still very much able to write a fully functioning iPhone app that did
我只需要做我多年来一直做、非常熟悉的老一套东西，而且完全没有问题。在很多方面，这最终甚至比他们推荐的方法还要快，因为开销更小。至少对于我的应用程序来说，效果很好。我不敢说这在所有情况下都适用，但我绝对没有因为只有扎实的C语言背景而不精通Objective-C而感到受阻。我依然能够写出一个功能齐全的iPhone应用，并且……
everything I needed to do and, you know, was well received. Yeah, I actually went through something similar where I, I made a little board game. I guess a board computer game. I don't know. I made a board game, but you know, not having the facilities to print large amounts of stock paper, I created an emulated version on the computer. I wanted it to run on the iPhone. And so I was taking this program that is actually written in Python, and converting it over to on the iPhone. And so I was taking this program that was actually written in Python and converting it over to Objective-C. And it converted over pretty well. So I think that, yeah, definitely, I think that I wouldn't pick Objective-C as my first language to learn either. I would pick a simpler language like C or like Python.
完成了我需要的所有功能，而且反响不错。是的，我其实也经历过类似的事情，我做了一个小棋盘游戏。我想应该叫棋盘电脑游戏吧，我不知道。我做了一个棋盘游戏，但因为没有设备去打印大量的纸质材料，我就在电脑上做了一个模拟版本。我想让它在iPhone上运行。所以我把这个原本用Python写的程序转换成了Objective-C。转换过程相当顺利。所以我认为，我绝对不会把Objective-C作为第一门要学的语言。我会选择像C或Python这样更简单的语言。
Something very much like text-based i think is kind of key there as silly as that sounds yeah i mean i think that when i read objective c and i don't know if it's because i started in c but everything seems a little backwards you know like it seems like i think things are out of order um in certain areas of it maybe the way that there's the things are nested but i always feel like i'm reading things backwards i think what it. Maybe the way that the things are nested. But I always feel like I'm reading things backwards. I think what it is, is how you put the brackets, and then you put the object and the function name inside the brackets, as opposed to object parentheses or function name parentheses.
我认为关键在于选择像文本驱动这类语言，尽管听起来有点傻。是的，我的意思是，当我阅读Objective-C代码时——我不知道是不是因为我起步于C语言——一切看起来都有点反直觉。在某些方面，事情的顺序似乎是乱的，也许是因为嵌套的方式，但我总觉得自己在倒着读代码。我想原因在于括号的使用方式，你把对象和函数名放在括号里，而不是像其他语言那样用对象加括号或函数名加括号。
Yeah, so that is a little bit getting used to. But one thing that should be mentioned is that the Xcode, which is the editor IDE you'll almost certainly be using if you're doing iPhone development, has a really nice slick UI for creating the UI for your app. So kind of like how Microsoft MFC used to be,
是的，这确实需要一点时间来适应。但有一点值得一提，那就是Xcode，如果你进行iPhone开发，几乎肯定会用到这个IDE，它有一个非常漂亮且流畅的UI界面，可以用来创建应用的界面。这有点像以前的微软MFC，
although MFC is the devil, but that's another story. They have this nice, Mac, actually, Apple did a great job. They have this resource builder where you can go in, drag buttons, kind of get an idea, mock up how your app is going to look. And then you can double click on the buttons to create little stub functions and things like that so you know like patrick said if you get a foundation in c or python or any other procedural language java you could take that to objective c and be able to do whatever you need to do on the iphone there yeah i i'd agree with that and i mean if if you really want to make an iphone app and that's really what motivates you,
虽然MFC简直是噩梦，但那是另一回事了。他们有一个很棒的资源构建器，你可以进去拖拽按钮，构思并模拟出你的应用外观。然后你可以双击按钮来创建存根函数之类的东西。所以就像Patrick说的，如果你有C、Python或任何其他过程式语言（比如Java）的基础，你就可以将其应用到Objective-C中，并完成你在iPhone上需要做的任何事情。是的，我同意这一点。我的意思是，如果你真的想做一个iPhone应用，而且这确实是你的动力，
by all means, please go ahead and learn Objective-C. And there's becoming more and more resources out there to do it. And the stuff you learn there will, just like we're saying other stuff will apply to that, what you learn in Objective-C will apply to other things. For sure. So that's what motivates you. I think it's just a word of caution to be careful to not get overwhelmed by you know the kind of graphical nature of this ios device versus you
那么无论如何，请尽管去学习Objective-C。现在相关的资源也越来越多了。你在那里学到的东西，就像我们说的，也会应用到其他地方。肯定的。所以，如果这就是你的动力，那很好。我只是想提醒一句，要小心不要被iOS设备的图形化特性所淹没，而……
know kind of just starting with simple text-based stuff yeah that's true definitely because graphics does add it's fun because it's really enjoyable to be able to see you know kind of animations and visually what's going on that's a really fun thing to do but it does add a whole layer of complexity that is it's hard especially for a beginner to figure out exactly what's going on and all you have to do yeah maybe we'll take a little bit of time here and talk about asynchronous because a lot of anything you're going to do with the user interface and if you're doing stuff on the iphone or the um you know osx or the ip anything you're going to do with the user interface, and if you're doing stuff on the iPhone or the OSX or the iPad, you're almost certainly going to have to deal with the user interface. As Patrick said, you're not really going to be writing console apps for the iPhone.
忽略了从简单的文本驱动内容开始。是的，确实如此，因为图形化确实很有趣，能够看到动画和视觉效果是非常享受的，这确实很有趣，但它增加了一整层复杂性，对于初学者来说，很难弄清楚到底发生了什么以及你需要做什么。是的，也许我们花点时间谈谈异步编程，因为你在iPhone、OSX或iPad上处理用户界面时，几乎肯定要面对异步问题。正如Patrick所说，你不会真的在iPhone上写控制台应用。
Before we do that, let me interject quickly that we've been talking about OSX and about the iPhone, but GCC actually does support Objective-C as well. And so you can write text-based command line programs that way. I don't really know of a lot of people doing that. The only people I know writing Objective-C are doing it for OSX or Cocoa or iOS. But there are a couple, also the LLVM CLang compiler will do objective c so you do have options on other platforms for doing that but it's mostly supported by apple and their products so
在我们开始之前，我快速插一句，我们一直在谈论OSX和iPhone，但GCC其实也支持Objective-C。所以你可以用它编写基于文本的命令行程序。我不太了解有多少人在这样做。我认识的写Objective-C的人都是为了OSX、Cocoa或iOS。但确实有一些，而且LLVM Clang编译器也支持Objective-C，所以你在其他平台上也有选择，但它主要还是由苹果及其产品支持的，所以……
that's where you're going to find i would dare to even say probably 99 of objective c development yeah for sure okay sorry so asynchronous so asynchronicity is something you have to worry about whenever you have a user interface. And basically, you might have wondered this. You know, I write this program, and somewhere along the line, it has a set of instructions. And then when that instruction finishes, my program ends. So, how can I write something like a user interface where it's kind of waiting on the user? So, you might think of, well, I'll just do kind of like a while true around my entire program.
这就是你会发现99%的Objective-C开发都在这里进行的原因。是的，肯定的。好的，抱歉，回到异步编程。只要你有用户界面，就必须考虑异步性。基本上，你可能想过这个问题：我写了这个程序，它有一系列指令。当指令执行完毕，程序就结束了。那么，我该如何编写像用户界面这样需要等待用户操作的程序呢？你可能会想，我可以在整个程序外面套一个“while true”循环。
And this while true will just continue to loop and sort of wait for the user to do something. And when the user does something, then there'll be some kind of action. And this is basically the heart of asynchronous programming. So what's going on here is basically you have sort of a while true, so you have some loop that's constantly running, but then within that loop it sort of asks a series of questions. And so these questions are getting asked, you know, hundreds, maybe thousands of times a second,
这个“while true”循环会不断运行，等待用户做些什么。当用户操作时，就会触发某种动作。这基本上就是异步编程的核心。所以这里发生的事情是，你有一个“while true”循环在不断运行，但在循环内部，它会询问一系列问题。这些问题每秒会被询问成百上千次，
maybe even more than that. So the questions might be, you know, has the user clicked on a button? Has the user moved the mouse? Has the user done anything? Maybe there's an idle function, you know, has the user clicked on a button? Has the user moved the mouse? Has the user done anything? Maybe there's an idle function, you know, has a second of time gone by? There's just a series of questions. Now all this is going on behind the scenes. You don't see any of this code. But if the user has, let's say, moved the mouse, then look for any, you know, mouse moved functions in the code. And by look for it, what I mean is actually you tell the operating system, or in this case, you tell the application layer. Called registering. Yep. So you might have some function where
甚至更多。这些问题可能是：用户点击按钮了吗？用户移动鼠标了吗？用户做了什么吗？也许有一个空闲函数，比如：一秒钟过去了吗？这只是一系列问题。所有这些都在后台进行，你看不到这些代码。但如果用户移动了鼠标，程序就会寻找代码中任何“鼠标移动”的函数。我所说的“寻找”，实际上是指你告诉操作系统，或者在这种情况下，你告诉应用程序层。这叫注册。是的。所以你可能有一个函数，
every time the user moves the mouse, it draws like a cute mouse trail or something like that. In that case, you're going to register this mouse moved function that case you're going to register this mouse moved function and you're going to bind a mouse moved callback to one of your functions. So when the mouse is moved then I'm going to you know add these little mouse trail pointer these little graphics. So writing asynchronous code if you look at the code what you'll see is some main function that just creates all these callbacks it just instantiates
每当用户移动鼠标时，它就会画出一条可爱的鼠标轨迹之类的东西。在这种情况下，你要注册这个“鼠标移动”函数，并将一个鼠标移动的回调绑定到你的函数上。所以当鼠标移动时，我就会添加这些鼠标轨迹指针或图形。因此，如果你查看异步代码，你会看到一个主函数，它只是创建了所有这些回调，它只是实例化了……
all these callbacks like you might have like main and then you know bind mouse move to my trail function bind user clicked on this button to my submit function all these binds and then just a go and what's going on behind the scenes when you call that go is there's just a loop and it's just going through and waiting for the user to do something and then reacting to it so this is something that as as programmers you know if you're used to writing sort of recipe kind of programs like C or C++, asynchronous programming can seem very scary. But it's something that you just kind of got to get familiar with. And once you start doing it, you'll quickly get the hang of it. The other thing that's confusing there that is worth pointing out is that if you kind of think about asynchronous you know just means not everything being synchronized
所有这些回调，比如你可能有“main”，然后绑定“鼠标移动”到我的轨迹函数，绑定“用户点击按钮”到我的提交函数，所有这些绑定，然后就是一个“go”。当你调用“go”时，后台发生的事情就是一个循环，它不断运行并等待用户操作，然后做出反应。所以，作为程序员，如果你习惯了写像C或C++那种“食谱式”的程序，异步编程看起来会很可怕。但你只需要熟悉它，一旦开始做，很快就能上手。另一件容易混淆且值得指出的事情是，如果你认为异步仅仅意味着“不同步”……
and in lock step so if you read a normal c program it's everything is operates one after the other and you can follow a line of execution straight through your program or if you've got a loop you know you can follow it through each cycle of the loop and then to the end of the program or whatever it means but it's kind of everything one right after the other when asynchronous comes in you don't know which parts of your code are going to operate in which order which is because you bind these functions to certain events and you don't know which one might get called before another and they can be called while you're off doing something else and so that introduces a kind of confusing thing to your code where you can't just read it like a book and the other thing is that you have to be careful because what happens is is there's a thread of
且不是步调一致的。如果你读一个普通的C程序，一切都是按顺序操作的，你可以顺着执行线一直读到程序末尾；或者如果你有一个循环，你可以跟着它走完每一轮循环。但当异步引入时，你不知道代码的哪一部分会以什么顺序运行，因为你将这些函数绑定到了特定的事件上，你不知道哪一个会先被调用，它们甚至可能在你做其他事情时被调用。这给你的代码引入了一种混乱，你不能像读一本书那样读它。另一件事是，你必须小心，因为有一个执行线程……
execution that is you know responsible for drawing all the stuff on your screen and so somebody clicks a button and in that button event handler you try to do some complex math like you try to solve the meaning of the universe. What's going to happen is during that time, the user is going to not be able to get a response out of your GUI. The buttons won't highlight when you move over them. They won't be able to resize a window. And if you've ever seen this happen in a program,
负责在屏幕上绘制所有东西。所以如果有人点击了一个按钮，而在那个按钮的事件处理程序中，你试图进行一些复杂的数学运算，比如试图计算宇宙的终极答案。会发生什么呢？在那段时间里，用户将无法从你的GUI中得到响应。当你把鼠标移到按钮上时，按钮不会高亮，用户也无法调整窗口大小。如果你曾经在程序中见过这种情况，
that's typically what the problem is. Something's gotten stuck somewhere doing a bunch of processing. It wasn't supposed to do in that thread, and now you're not getting a response out of the GUI. So the right way to handle that is in the message, well, handle it in the handler, is to push that work to another thread or to some other something that's going to do that processing that's going to take longer so that that function can return and the GUI can continue to be updated so that the user maintains responsiveness right so one thing I probably
那通常就是问题所在。有些东西卡在某个地方进行大量处理，它本不应该在那个线程中进行，现在你的GUI没有响应了。所以正确的处理方法是在处理程序中，将这些工作推送到另一个线程或某个其他能进行处理的地方，这样该函数可以立即返回，GUI可以继续更新，从而保持用户的响应性。对，所以有一件事我可能……
should mention you know in addition to in that while loop that I talked about before where it's checking to see did the user click a button did the user move the mouse etc there's also uh what Patrick alluded to I draw the screen and and as he's saying, if you interrupt that while loop, if you halt that while loop by solving the meaning of the universe, it can't get to that draw the screen, draw the screen. The user moved the mouse, draw the screen, draw the new mouse. It can't do any of that. And so a lot of asynchronous programs will,
应该提到，除了我之前谈到的那个检查用户是否点击按钮、移动鼠标等的“while循环”之外，还有Patrick提到的“绘制屏幕”。正如他所说，如果你通过计算宇宙终极答案来中断那个循环，它就无法执行“绘制屏幕”的操作。用户移动了鼠标，需要绘制屏幕，绘制新的鼠标位置，它什么都做不了。所以很多异步程序会……
if you have a threading library, they'll say, okay, you clicked on this button to submit your information to the website while I'm contacting the website and submitting the information etc let's push that off onto a separate thread so that this main thread can continue running or let's break this up into pieces so if you click on you know Graph, and it's going to take all this data that you've put into your phone, it's kind of like Excel. It's going to fit a curve to your data and display it on screen for you to do whatever
如果你有一个线程库，它们会说，好的，你点击了这个按钮来提交信息到网站，当我在联系网站并提交信息时，让我们把它推送到一个单独的线程，这样主线程可以继续运行。或者让我们把它拆分成小块，这样如果你点击了“图表”，它会获取你输入到手机里的所有数据，就像Excel一样。它会拟合曲线并显示在屏幕上供你使用。它可能会把这个过程拆分，它可能会说，绘制曲线，然后在下一次循环时，查找一些数据。下一次循环时，将数据拟合到曲线，然后再下一次循环时，查找数据。下一次循环时，将数据拟合到曲线。所以每次循环时，你都在检查用户是否移动了鼠标，你在绘制屏幕，然后你只做了一点点工作。所以GUI实际上是被暂停了，但时间极短，没人能察觉到。
with. It might break that up into pieces, and it might say, draw the curve, and then the next time it goes through the loop, find some data. The next time it goes through the loop, fit the data to the curve, and then the next time it goes through the loop, find some data. The next time it goes through the loop, fit the data to the curve. And so every time you're going through the loop, you're checking, did the user move the mouse, you're drawing the screen, and then you're doing just a little bit of work. And so the GUI is actually being halted, but by such a tiny amount that nobody can notice.
所以这些通常是异步编程的核心特征。但GUI代码绝对比普通的同步代码更难阅读。是的。因为这些事实。没错。而且互联网代码更难，因为你通常有成百上千甚至上万的用户同时使用同一个东西。是的，这可能会引出我们未来要讨论的一些话题，比如人们在Web服务器方面正在探索的一些有趣的新方向，以及如何从一个程序处理大量用户。是的，绝对的。
So these are often the core features you see in asynchronous programming. But GUI code is definitely more confusing to read than normal synchronous code. Yeah. Because of these facts. Right. And internet code is even harder because you typically have hundreds maybe thousands of users all using the same thing at the same time. Yeah, which will lead to maybe some stuff we'll talk about in the future, some interesting new directions people are going in web servers and how to handle large numbers of users from one program. Yeah, definitely.
我们未来一定要深入探讨一些互联网话题。是的，那些非常实用，而且我认为很多人都在做这些。我们应该小心，在谈论学习编程时——虽然我们刚才偏离了Objective-C的话题——很多人会因为你的选择而对你指手画脚。“哦，我不敢相信你学了BASIC”或者“我不敢相信你学了PHP，那不是真正的编程语言”。有时我发现这些人往往是那些自己并不懂行的人，他们这么说只是因为无知和感到威胁，或者……
We should definitely get into some more Internet topics in the future. Yeah, those are very applicable, and I think a lot of people are out there doing that and uh you know we should be careful that you know when talking about learning to program which i guess we kind of got off of when we were on objective c but that you know a lot of people will kind of uh fuss at you about your choice oh i can't believe you learned basic or i can't believe you learned php that's not a real programming language uh sometimes i find that those people tend to be the people that don't know what they're doing and so they're just saying that because they're ignorant and they're threatened or
无论是什么原因，这就像学校里那些嘲笑你的人。记得那些人吗？通常是因为他们自己有某种巨大的缺陷，他们试图通过嘲笑别人来掩盖它。是的，所以永远不要因为你的选择而感到尴尬。很有趣的是，正如你所说，那些最沮丧的人，通常是因为他们根本看不到他们所嘲笑的东西的好处。但事实是，我们谈论的所有这些语言，以及我们可能要谈论的所有语言（除非我们真的没语言可谈了），都是非常流行的，而且……
you know whatever it is it's kind of like the people that make fun of you in school you know remember those people it typically because they had some sort of huge flaw themselves and they were trying to cover it up by making fun of everybody else uh yeah i mean so never be embarrassed by your choice it's so interesting how you know often like you're saying the people who are the most despondent are the people who it's typically that they just don't they cannot see the benefit of whatever they're you know making fun of but the fact is that all these languages that we've talked about until now and likely all the ones we're going to talk about unless we really start running out of languages are are very popular and
它们具有难以置信的实用性。所以，关键在于为正确的工作选择正确的工具。没错，如果你在写iOS程序，Objective-C绝对是正确的工具。所以我们谈论了很多它的优点，但也许我们应该涵盖一些Objective-C的缺点。我们刚才一直在暗示第一个缺点，那就是除了这些用途之外，没人真的用Objective-C做任何事。事实上，如果我没理解错的话，苹果发布了Objective-C语言的第二个版本，或者说Objective-C编译器，或者无论你怎么称呼它，那次升级甚至没有得到其他人的支持，因为在OSX/iOS环境之外，没有足够多的人对使用这些语言特性感兴趣。
they have an incredible amount of utility so um it's all about picking the right tool for the right job that's right and if you're writing ios programs that's objective c that's definitely the right tool for sure so we talked about a lot of the strengths but maybe we should cover some of the weaknesses of objective c we kind of been hinting around the first one that i have which is that outside of these uses nobody really uses objective c for anything in fact um if i if i understand correctly apple kind of released the second version of objective c language or the c compile objective c compiler or however you want to phrase it kind of the upgrade and that's not even supported by anybody else like gccive-C don't support those language features because there's just not enough people interested in using this outside of the OSX iOS environment.
是的，没错。用户基数小是它最大的弱点。而且，现在我想有些人已经找到了在不使用Objective-C的情况下为iPhone编写应用的方法。我见过这个Corona SDK，它是一个iPhone开发工具包，你可以用C++编写，我不知道他们在后台做了什么。是的，我以为有类似的东西。我对那个话题不太了解，没准备好，但我知道有一段时间，他们的许可协议里基本上说你必须使用苹果认为合适的开发环境来编写Objective-C，不允许写其他任何东西。我想人们对此有些不满，我想他们稍微退让了一点，但我认为总的来说，他们的立场仍然是你应该总是运行Objective-C或用Objective-C编写。是的，是的，我认为iPhone上99%的代码仍然是Objective-C。但确实，还有其他方法。
Yeah, that's right. Yeah, the low user base is by far the biggest weakness. And, you know, now I think that some people have figured out ways to write, you know, apps for the iPhonehone without using objective c i've seen uh this corona sdk it's a development kit for the iphone where you can write in i think c++ and i don't know what they're doing behind the scenes yeah i thought there was something i i i'm not that fresh on i wasn't prepared for that topic but um i know there was a while where they had something in the license agreement that basically said you had to write an objective c with apple's
我认为Boo是Python的一种方言，可以在一定程度上用于iPhone。但归根结底，如果你是为iPhone编写程序，最好的建议就是忍一忍，学习Objective-C。我们在编写iPhone应用时就是这么做的。我要说的Objective-C的另一个缺点是……
you know deemed appropriate development environments and you weren't allowed to write anything else and i think people kind of fussed and i think they backed off of it a little but i think in general that's still their stance is that you're supposed to always run Objective-C or write in Objective-C. Yeah, yeah, I think that, you know, it's still 99% of the code on the iPhone, I would say, is Objective-C. But yeah, there are ways.
它的语法非常冗长且复杂。但这可能是因为我们先入为主地受到了C++程序员思维的影响。嗯，我感觉是这样，但我认为客观地说，回到Objective-C的优点，即动态和静态类型，还有……哦，有一件事我们没怎么谈，就是不同的属性指令。在Objective-C中创建属性非常容易。但仅仅为了获得那种能力……
I think Boo is a dialect of Python, which can be used on the iPhone in some capacity. But yeah, I mean, in the end, if you're writing for the iPhone, really the best advice is to just suck it up and learn Objective-C. We did for writing our iPhone apps. One of the other weaknesses I would say about Objective-C
和引用计数等功能，我觉得是以语法为代价的。我觉得我可以客观地说，像C语言这样没有那么多花哨功能的语言，语法要简单得多。但话说回来，这很大程度上是因为……等等，等等，等等，我不知道我们能不能让这种说法通过。C语言语法简单？好吧，你见过我见过的一些C代码吗？哦，是的。C代码可能非常糟糕。我想任何代码……
is that it's just the syntax is, I feel like it's very verbose and complicated. But maybe that's because we're colored by being C++ programmers first. Well, I feel like that, but I feel like objectively what I can say is that, you know, going back to the strengths of Objective-C, being, you know, dynamically and statically typed, having the, oh, one thing we didn't really talk about was the different property directives. It's very easy to create properties in Objective-C. But just being able to get that power
都可能很糟糕。但也许这是一个更公平的说法：如果你为iPhone编写程序，你几乎肯定会进行异步编程。所以并没有什么典型的“Hello World”。没有一个……
and the reference counting, things like that, comes at the cost of the syntax, I feel. I feel like i could be objective and say that a language like c which doesn't have all the bells and whistles um you know has a much simpler to read syntax but you know again a lot of that is because whoa whoa hang on hang on hang on i don't know if we can let that fly c has a simple syntax well have you seen some of the c code I've seen? Oh, yeah. C code could be terrible. I guess any code
庞大的、用Objective-C编写的、直观的命令行代码库供你练手。所以很有可能，如果你要学习这门语言，你就要上手一个异步的iPhone应用，
could be. But maybe this is a more fair statement. If you're writing for the iPhone, you will almost certainly be doing asynchronous programming. And so there aren't really any canonical hello world. There isn't a
其中有许多不同的函数调用到处乱飞。我认为这足以让任何语言变得复杂。好吧。是的，我的意思是，我是在为难你。我同意这门语言在我看来有很多你并不真正需要的字符。是的，你知道，这在很多这类UI中确实是普遍存在的。记得MFC吗？那简直是一场灾难。就像是……
large code base of command line, straightforward code written in Objective-C for you to get your feet wet. So chances are, if you're going to learn the language, you're going to take on an asynchronous iPhone app
应用程序层、整数指针，所有这些词串在一起，仅仅是为了给UI上的一个按钮命名一个变量。所以MFC有这个问题。你知道，Java，甚至Java也有这个问题，比如“new file reader”，然后在里面嵌套“new buffered reader”、“new io reader”。所以任何时候你开始处理GUI用户体验之类的事情，它都会变得非常冗长。所以我认为这只是因为Objective-C只用于这类应用程序。好吧，这意味着你将不得不阅读大量复杂的代码。我同意这一点。这并不是什么……我们的播客是“Programming Throwdown”，我原以为我们会多争论一下，但……
with many different function calls going all over the place. And I think that's enough to make any language complicated. Okay. Yeah, I mean, I'm giving you a hard time i agree that the language in my opinion has a lot of characters that you don't really need yeah and you know this is really endemic to a lot of these sort of uh these sort of uis i mean remember mfc and what a disaster that was? Like, it was like application
结果并没有那样。是的，好吧，我认为我们偶尔会互相拷问一下。我认为我们应该选一门有争议的语言。也许下次我们做C++，那门语言至少我是非常有主见的。我不知道你怎么样。我可以接受任何与你相反的观点。放马过来吧。你绝对是错的。
layer, integer pointer, like all of those words strung together just to like to name a variable for a freaking button on a UI. And so MFC had this problem. You know, Java, even Java has this problem, like new file reader, and then inside of that new buffered reader new io reader so anytime you start dealing with um you know gui user experience kind of things it's going to become very verbose and so i think it's just um the fact that objective c is only used for those kind of applications okay that means that you're going to be yeah reading a lot of complicated code i'll agree to agree with that this isn't much of a you know our our podcast is programming throwdown we you know i kind of thought maybe we'd throw it down with each other a little more but
不。我们只会进行一场哭泣比赛。好吧，为了结束这一期，既然我们有点跑题了，我想感谢所有的听众。感谢那些给我们写邮件和在iTunes上写好评的人。请继续这样做。这让我们觉得做这项工作是值得的。
it hasn't really turned out that way yeah well i think that you know every now and then we kind of grill each other i think that we should pick a language that has much contention. Maybe we'll do C++ next time, one where at least I'm very opinionated. I don't know about you. I can take whatever opinion that is opposite of yours. Bring it on. You are definitely wrong.
我们很享受做这件事，但知道它是有价值的，因为有人在听，这很有帮助。而且这有助于我们获得更多的听众，因为它提高了我们的排名，让其他人能看到我们。所以我鼓励大家，点击五星好评很好，四星也可以，但请尽量给五星。如果能写一点留言告诉我们你喜欢什么，那就更好了。如果你有什么不喜欢的地方，就把好的写在评论里，然后给我们发邮件或在博客上发布你的评论和批评，
No. We'll just have a crying match. Well, to close this up, since we're drifting a little, I want to thank all of our listeners. Thank you for those who have written us some emails and written us some good reviews in iTunes. Continue to do that, please. That helps us feel appreciated for doing this work.
这样我们就可以尝试改进。欢迎在我们的网站 programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com 上发布评论。你会找到节目笔记、我们谈论过的一些内容的链接，以及我们讨论的简要回顾，以防你以后记不住某些东西。如果你像我一样记忆力很差的话。是的，我也是。
And we enjoy doing it, but it helps to know that it's worth it because people are out there listening to it and uh it helps us get even more listeners because it rises us in the rank so other people can see us so i encourage you please not it's nice to click click the five star review and four stars reviews please five stars and uh but it's it's even nicer if you can write a little message and tell us what you like about it and then if you have something you don't like so much just write the good things in the review and then send us an email or post it on the blog, your comments and critiques
好的，Jason也是。而且，如果你想下载播客，网站上也有链接。看起来大多数人通过iTunes下载，但如果你想在电脑上听或者下载到其他设备上，你可以在网站上找到。是的，顺便提一下，感谢Weston提出了关于我们为什么决定开始编程以及关于Objective-C的节目创意。
so we can try to make things better and feel free to post on those we do on our website programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com you'll find show notes, links to some of the stuff we talked about, kind of a little bit of a recap of our discussion in case you can't remember something later. If you have terrible memory, like at least I do. Yeah, same here.
所以，如果你有任何意见或建议，我们随时洗耳恭听。那是一个特别好的建议。是的，不能保证我们会实现你说的或做的。但我们一定会读，一定会听。而且我们可能会在节目中提到你。
Okay, and Jason too. And, you know, also a link to the podcast if you want to download it. It looks like most people download through iTunes, but if you want to listen to it on your computer or download it for another device, you can find that on the website. Yeah, and I mean, a shout out to Weston for coming up with both of the ideas for the show for why we decided to start programming
好的，我想节目就到这里了。好的，下次见。祝大家过得愉快，保重。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的《Axo》。好的，下次见，祝大家过得愉快，保重。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and for Objective-C. So definitely, if you have any comments or suggestions, we do have our ears open. And that was a particularly good one. Yeah, can't promise that we'll implement what you say or do it. But we'll definitely read it. We'll definitely listen to it. And we'll probably give you a shout out on the show.
以及Objective-C。所以，如果你有任何意见或建议，我们绝对洗耳恭听。那是一个非常好的建议。是的，我们不能保证一定会采纳或执行你们说的内容，但我们一定会阅读，一定会倾听，而且很可能会在节目中提到你们。
Yeah, so I think that about wraps it up. All right. Well, until next time. Have a good one, guys. Take care. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. alright well till next time have a good one guys take care There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，我想节目就到这里了。好的，那么下次见。祝大家过得愉快，保重。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的《Axo》。好的，下次见，祝大家过得愉快，保重。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。